Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. At Wealthsimple, we're built for whatever you're building. Built for Jane, who wants to break into the housing market. We're built for Ted, who's obsessed with what's happening in the global markets. And built for Celine, who just wants to retire and explore the world's flea markets. So take a moment and think about what you're building for. We've got the financial tools to help make it happen. Wealthsimple. Built for possibilities.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在 Wealthsimple，我们为您正在构筑的一切保驾护航。为了想要进军房地产市场的简（Jane）而创立。我们为痴迷于全球市场动态的泰德（Ted）而创立。也为了只想退休并探索世界跳蚤市场的席琳（Celine）而创立。所以，花点时间想想你在为之奋斗的目标。我们拥有实现这一目标所需的金融工具。Wealthsimple。成就无限可能。
Visit wealthsimple. Built for possibilities. Visit wealthsimple.com slash possibilities. Ladies and gentlemen, I'm only going to talk to you just for a minute or so this evening because I have some very sad news for all of you and I think sad news for all of our fellow citizens and people who love peace all over the world. And that is that Martin Luther King was shot and was killed tonight in Memphis, Tennessee. Martin Luther King dedicated his life to love and to justice between fellow human beings. He died in the cause of that effort. In this difficult day, in this difficult time for the United States, it's perhaps well to ask what kind of a nation we are and
访问 Wealthsimple。成就无限可能。访问 wealthsimple.com/possibilities。女士们先生们，今晚我只想和大家说上一分钟左右，因为我有一些非常悲伤的消息要告诉大家，我认为这也是对我们所有同胞以及全世界热爱和平的人们来说悲伤的消息。那就是，马丁·路德·金今晚在田纳西州孟菲斯市遭到枪击身亡。马丁·路德·金将他的一生奉献给了同胞之间的爱与正义。他为这一事业付出了生命。在这艰难的一天，在这个对美国来说艰难的时刻，我们或许应该问问自己，我们究竟是一个什么样的国家，以及
what direction we want to move in. For those of you who are black, you can be filled with bitterness and with hatred and a desire for revenge. We can move in that direction as a country in greater polarization, black people amongst blacks and white amongst whites, filled with hatred toward one another. Or we can make an effort as Martin Luther King did, to understand and to comprehend and replace that violence, that stain of bloodshed that has spread across our land with an effort to understand compassion and love. compassion and love. So that was Robert F. Kennedy on the 4th of April 1968, speaking to a crowd in Indianapolis, a crowd that was largely black and who when Bobby Kennedy stood up to give that speech, didn't know that Martin Luther King had been shot. So at the beginning
我们想要朝哪个方向前进。对于你们当中的黑人来说，你们可能会充满痛苦、仇恨和复仇的渴望。作为这个国家，我们可以朝着那个方向前进，陷入更深的对立，黑人对黑人，白人对白人，彼此心中充满仇恨。或者我们可以像马丁·路德·金那样，努力去理解、去包容，用理解、同情和爱，去取代那场暴力、那片蔓延在我们国土上的血腥污渍。同情和爱。那么，刚才那是罗伯特·F·肯尼迪于1968年4月4日在印第安纳州向人群发表的讲话，人群中大部分是黑人，当鲍比·肯尼迪起身发表那篇讲话时，他们并不知道马丁·路德·金已经被枪杀。所以在那个
of that interview, you listen to it, you can hear, I assume Kennedy's aides in the background kind of talking about, do they know, do people know what's the news? And then he stands up and it's completely extemporized, isn't it? So it's an amazing speech under the circumstances. And of course, what enhances the sense of drama
采访的开头，你听一下，我猜你可以听到肯尼迪的助手们在背景里讨论，他们知道吗？人们知道吗？有什么新闻？然后他站起来，完全是即兴发挥的，对吧？所以在这种情况下，这是一场了不起的演讲。当然，什么增强了那种戏剧感
and tragedy about it is of course that Bobby Kennedy himself is the brother of drama and tragedy about it is of course that Bobby Kennedy himself is the brother of a man who had been assassinated and in due course will himself go on to be shot. Yeah, agreed. So you did two versions of that, didn't you, of that speech? And the second one, I thought was pretty good. The warm up was a kind of cross between the Kaiser and Bugs Bunny. Yeah, I felt it didn't adequately convey the sense of tragedy and pathos that I genuinely want to because this is actually, I mean, as I say, a very, very moving and powerful speech.
和悲剧色彩呢？当然是因为鲍比·肯尼迪本人就是那种戏剧感和悲剧色彩的兄弟……呃，我是说，鲍比·肯尼迪本人就是一个曾被暗杀的人的兄弟，而且在不久的将来，他自己也将遭到枪击。是的，完全同意。所以你把那段演讲排练了两个版本，对吧？第二个版本，我觉得挺不错的。热身部分有点像是凯撒大帝和兔八哥的结合体。是的，我觉得它没有充分传达出我真心想表达的那种悲剧感和哀伤，因为这实际上——正如我所说——是一场非常、非常感人且充满力量的演讲。
It is, totally. I hope that I have done it sufficient justice that people get some sense of that. I think your version was really good, Tom. I'm not going to stamp on it. I am going to say that if listeners want to go on YouTube, they can hear the speech and it is very, very moving to hear the electricity in the air, the shock of the crowd, Kennedy's kind of reedy voice. Rawness. Yeah, rawness. The rawness of it. And am I right that this is almost the only time he ever talks in public about the assassination of his brother, JFK? Exactly. We'll come onto the second part of the speech in our next episode. But you're absolutely right.
确实如此，完全同意。我希望我能做到足够的公正，让人们能感受到这一点。我觉得你的版本真的很棒，汤姆。我不会否定你的。我要说的是，如果听众想去 YouTube 上听听这段演讲，他们可以听到，而且能真切感受到空气中弥漫的电流感、人群的震惊、肯尼迪那种略带沙哑的嗓音，这真的非常非常感人。那种原始的冲击力。是的，那种原始感。那种原始的张力。我没记错的话，这几乎是他唯一一次在公众场合谈论他的兄弟、美国总统肯尼迪（JFK）的遇刺事件吧？正是如此。我们将在下一集中探讨演讲的第二部分。但你绝对没说错。
It's one of the only times really where he lays himself bare in that way in front of a crowd at a moment that is so charged with tension, because as you say, the crowd is largely black in Indianapolis. So we ended the last episode with Lynch and Johnson pulling out of the presidential race. Kennedy has only been in the campaign for a few days. So we are now what five days after Johnson pulled out and we have that sense now of events piling on events. So today's episode is all about Martin Luther King, his final days and his assassination,
这确实是他唯一一次在如此充满紧张气氛的时刻，在人群面前如此赤裸地袒露心声，因为正如你所说，印第安纳州的人群中很大一部分是黑人。所以我们在上一集的结尾讲到了林奇和约翰逊退出总统竞选。肯尼迪参选才区区几天。所以我们现在正处于约翰逊退选五天后，我们能感受到事件一件接着一件地叠加压顶。所以今天的节目全是关于马丁·路德·金、他生命的最后几天以及他的遇刺事件，
one of the most tragic moments in American history. So perhaps we should set the scene a bit because we have had Martin Luther King on the podcast before. Some listeners may remember we did that episode about his I have a dream speech. We did it on location, didn't we? Yeah. In Washington. So we ended that episode.
这是美国历史上最悲剧的时刻之一。所以或许我们应该先做点铺垫，因为我们之前在播客里也聊过马丁·路德·金。有些听众可能还记得，我们做过一期关于他“我有一个梦想”演讲的节目。我们是在现场录制的，对吧？对的。在华盛顿。所以我们在那一集的结尾……
It's kind of King's high point. King was one of the most admired men on the planet. In 1964, Americans named him their fourth most admired man in the world behind President Johnson, Winston Churchill, and President Eisenhower. Interestingly if you track him, King's popularity very obviously declines in the next few years. So by 1966 he had fallen off the list entirely and actually the Gallup poll showed that six out of ten Americans now viewed King unfavorably. Now given that he's now a secular saint, Martin of King Day and so on, a lot
这可以说是金的巅峰时刻。金曾是这个星球上最受敬仰的人物之一。1964年，美国人将他评为世界上第四受敬仰的人，排在约翰逊总统、温斯顿·丘吉尔和艾森豪威尔总统之后。有趣的是，如果你追踪他的民调，金的人气在接下来的几年里明显下降。所以到了1966年，他已经完全跌出了榜单，事实上加勒普民意测验显示，十分之六的美国人现在对金持否定态度。鉴于他现在已经是一位世俗圣人、马丁·路德·金日等等，很多人
of people may find that surprising. How could people view him unfavorably? And it's a complicated story, but one reason for it is that having previously had his civil rights campaign in the South. So King is of course a Baptist minister. He's from Atlanta, Georgia. He's spent so much of his time in Alabama and Mississippi and Georgia and so on. But now he's been moving to the North. So he and other activists are conscious that actually there are enormous numbers of African Americans in the great cities of the North. They had moved there in the first half of the 20th century. And their plight, they're not subject to de jure segregation as they are in the South. Their lives aren't
可能会觉得这很惊讶。人们怎么会对他持否定态度呢？这是一个复杂的故事，但原因之一是，他之前一直在美国南部开展民权运动。所以金当然是一位浸信会牧师。他来自佐治亚州亚特兰大，在阿拉巴马州、密西西比州和佐治亚州等地度过了大量时间。但现在他正向北方转移。所以他和同僚们意识到，事实上，在北方的各大城市里有数量庞大的非裔美国人。他们在20世纪前半叶搬到了那里。他们的困境在于，他们不像在南方那样遭受法定种族隔离，但他们的生活也并不
brilliant either. They are much more likely than white, they're white neighbours to be unemployed, subject to informal discrimination as it were of various kinds, housing discrimination and so on. Their schools in black areas tend to be less well funded than white schools. They suffer police brutality, all of these kinds of things. The implication of that presumably is unsettling for everyone in the United States, because it implies that racial prejudice isn't just something that is legislated for or a legacy of the South or the Confederacy. That it is something that is a poison within the entire fabric of the United States, North as well as South.
好过。他们比白人邻居——白人邻居们——更有可能失业，遭受各种形式的非正式歧视，比如住房歧视等等。黑人地区的学校往往比白人学校获得的资助要少。他们遭受警察暴力，诸如此类的事情。这其中的潜台词大概让全美国的人都感到不安，因为它暗示种族偏见不仅仅是通过立法产生的东西，也不是南方或邦联的遗毒。它是整个美国社会肌体内部的一种毒药，北方和南方概莫能外。
Exactly, exactly. And when King does go North, so he went North in the summer of 1966 to Chicago. And he tries to dramatize this as he had dramatized the discrimination in the deep South, it doesn't really work. So he campaigns against housing segregation in the streets of Chicago. His march is the subject of intense violence, intense hostility from working class, blue collar, kind of white Chicagoans, also from the city authorities who are Democrats. They give him no cooperation at all.
完全正确，完全正确。当金真的来到北方——他在1966年夏天去了北方，去了芝加哥。他试图将这一点戏剧化，就像他在美国深南部将歧视戏剧化那样，但这并不真的管用。因此他在芝加哥街头开展反住房隔离运动。他的游行遭到了来自工人阶级、蓝领阶层的白人芝加哥居民的强烈暴力和敌意，同时也遭到了身为民主党人的市政府当局的敌意。他们完全不予配合。
The local press accused him of being in league with kind of organized crime to create confusion and turbulence and to compound danger to Chicagoans. And King actually comes back from Chicago and he says, my goodness, this is worse than anything I'd ever faced in the South. It is more entrenched, more vicious, partly because it's not a question, as you said, Thomas, not a question of kind of the legacy of slavery and laws. It is in people's imaginations. It is intangible, I guess.
当地媒体指责他与有组织犯罪勾结，制造混乱和动荡，并加剧了对芝加哥市民的威胁。金从芝加哥回来后实际上说，天哪，这比我在南方面对过的任何事情都要糟糕。它根深蒂固，更加恶毒，部分原因正如你所说，托马斯，这不仅是奴隶制和法律遗留问题的问题。它存在于人们的想象中。我想，它是无形的。
Mind-forged manacles. Exactly. There's a sense, I think, as well well that he's very discomforted by the rightward turn in American politics more generally. So the big gains for the Republicans in the 1966 midterms about law and order. Journalists start saying to him, come on, are you still going on about this? There's a famous exchange with CBS's Mike Wallace who says, don't you find that the American people are getting a little tired truly of this whole civil rights struggle? King finds this clearly very demoralizing. He finds it hard to raise money, his staff are becoming exhausted, kind
心灵铸就的枷锁。没错。而且我认为还有一种感觉，那就是他对美国政治更广泛的右转趋势感到非常不安。因此，1966年中期选举中共和党在法律与秩序问题上取得了巨大收益。记者们开始对他说：“行了，你还在喋喋不休地谈论这个吗？”CBS的迈克·华莱士曾与他进行过一次著名的对话，华莱士说：“难道你不觉得美国人民真的对这整个民权斗争感到有点厌烦了吗？”金显然觉得这非常令人士气低落。他发现筹款变得困难，他的工作人员精疲力竭，
of fractious, all of this kind of thing. Can I also just ask you, you mentioned the Republican gains in 1966 and said that this is focused on law and order. And it's a theme throughout the 60s, isn't it, that law and order is a bit of a dog whistle, that it is a way for white politicians to stoke racial anxieties among white voters without actually being overtly racist. Is that fair or not fair? Both. That's a very evasive answer. So I think it's perfectly reasonable to be very anxious about crime because crime has been shooting up so much. But I think there is also a degree to which it is also a dogma. And we will do two episodes in this series on George Wallace
意见分歧，诸如此类的事情。我能顺便问一下吗，你刚才提到1966年共和党的胜利，并说这集中在法律与秩序上。这是整个60年代的一个主题，不是吗？法律与秩序有点像是一种带有暗示的狗哨政治，它是白人政客在不公开表现出种族主义的情况下，激起白人选民种族焦虑的一种方式。这样说公道吗？还是不公道？两方面都有。这是一个非常敷衍的回答。所以，我认为对犯罪感到非常焦虑是完全合理的，因为犯罪率一直在急剧上升。但我认为，在某种程度上它也成了一种教条。我们将在本系列的接下来的两期节目中专门讨论乔治·华莱士
and Richard Nixon where we'll really explore that because of course both of them really go for the law and order issue. So yeah, you're right. And Reagan is also kind of a little bit playing with that. Absolutely. Reagan wins California in 66. You know, law and order is a huge part of his campaign. So King is already, you know, he's already, as it were, the love affair between him and the American public, such as it was, has gone sour. But what makes this a lot worse is Vietnam.
和理查德·尼克松，我们将深入探讨这一点，因为他们两人当然都极力利用法律与秩序问题。所以是的，你说得对。里根也在某种程度上打这张牌。完全正确。里根在66年赢得了加州。你知道，法律与秩序是他的竞选活动中非常重要的一部分。所以金当时已经——正如我所说，他和美国公众之间原本就有的那点蜜月期已经变味了。但让情况变得更糟的是越南战争。
Vietnam is going to run through this whole 68 series. It's like a poison. King had really come out against it in 1967. He had gone public in February, 1967 as a conference. He had talked about this horror at the children with napalm, the broken bodies in the fields. What are we doing sending home half men mutilated mentally and physically? He then gave one of his greatest speeches. I mean, some people might say he's actually the greatest speech he ever gave.
越南战争贯穿了整个68系列的节目。它就像一种毒药。金在1967年真正站出来反对它。他在1967年2月的一次会议上公开表态。他谈到了自己对那些遭受凝固汽油弹袭击的儿童、田野里残缺尸体的恐惧。我们把那些精神和身体受到残害、半身不遂的人送回家，到底在做什么？接着他发表了最伟大的演讲之一。我的意思是，有些人甚至可能会说这是他发表过的最伟大的演讲。
April, 1967 at the Riverside Church in New York. And he talks about how he has wrestled with the issue because he knows how controversial it is, but he feels that as a man of the cloth, he has a duty. He cannot stay silent any longer. And he gives this magnificent denunciation of the war. And he talks, you know, we have corrupted women and children, we have killed their men. He talks about the children, they wander into the towns, people see thousands of children homeless without clothes, running in packs like animals, children degraded by our soldiers as they beg for food, children selling their sisters to our soldiers, soliciting for their mothers. You know, it's really powerful stuff.
1967年4月，在纽约的河滨教堂。他谈到自己是如何与这个问题做斗争的，因为他知道这是多么具有争议性，但他觉得作为一名神职人员，他有责任。他再也不能保持沉默了。他发表了这场慷慨激昂的对战争的谴责。他说，我们堕落了妇女和儿童，我们杀害了他们的男人。他谈到了那些孩子们，他们游荡在城镇里，人们看到成千上万的儿童无家可归、衣不蔽体、像动物一样成群结队地奔跑，孩子们在乞讨食物时遭到我们士兵的贬低，孩子们把自己的姐妹卖给我们的士兵，为他们的母亲拉皮条。你知道，这真的是非常有冲击力的内容。
And presumably we talked in the previous episode about how LBJ feels betrayed by progressives who've turned against him. Yes. But this is a break. Completely. Between Martin Luther King and the guy who was steering through the civil rights legislation. Yeah, completely.
而且大概就像我们在上一集里讨论的那样，LBJ（约翰逊）感到自己被那些背叛他的进步派背叛了。是的。但这是一个彻底的决裂。彻底决裂。发生在马丁·路德·金与那个曾经全力推动民权立法的人之间。是的，彻底决裂。
So again, both sides are feeling betrayed by the other, I guess. Completely, they are. The Johnson White House feel completely betrayed by King and their relationship is effectively at an end. And actually, it's not just Johnson. The mainstream kind of democratic liberal press turn on King as well. The New York Times said it was wasteful and self-defeating. What's he doing talking about Vietnam?
所以同样，我猜双方都觉得被对方背叛了。完全是的，他们确实这么觉得。约翰逊的白宫感到彻底被金背叛了，他们之间的关系实际上已经走到了尽头。事实上，不只是约翰逊。主流的民主党自由派媒体也开始攻击金。《纽约时报》称这是浪费且自我挫败的。他谈论越南干什么？
He should be talking about civil rights. Life magazine accused him of quote, a demagogic slander that sounded like a script for radio Hanoi. You know, he's on the wrong side of the debate, I guess. And isn't there another factor as well that Martin Luther King, I mean, his great cause is peaceful protest, but he has coming up on his kind of left wing, I guess, his left flank, he has black activists who are not committed to that, who are actually quite in favour of armed violence. Yeah, absolutely. Violence was built into the narrative of the civil rights movement
他应该谈论民权。 《生活》杂志指责他发表了“恶毒的诽谤，听起来就像是河内广播电台的稿子”。你知道，我猜他站在了辩论的错误一边。而且难道还有一个因素吗，那就是马丁·路德·金——我的意思是，他伟大的事业是和平抗议，但在他的左翼，我猜在政坛的左翼，有一些不致力于这种方式、实际上相当赞成武装暴力的黑人激进分子在崛起。是的，绝对是这样。暴力本来就根植于民权运动的叙事之中，
because of course when they organised all those marches in the south, they knew they bargained for the fact that they would be attacked, that they would be mistreated by the police and the police with their dogs and all of that kind of stuff. And they would go to prison and everything. And they would publicly suffer. Non-violence, suffering publicly while other people attack you is a very important part of their strategy. I mean, Martin Luther King obviously is, as you said, he's a pastor.
因为当然，当他们在南方组织所有那些游行时，他们心里有数，他们做好了会被攻击的心理准备，做好了被警察以及警察带着警犬等等非人对待的心理准备。他们会进监狱，经受这一切。他们会公开受难。非暴力，在别人攻击你时公开承受苦难，是他们战略中非常重要的一部分。我的意思是，马丁·路德·金显然，正如你所说，他是一位牧师。
He is aware of the biblical echoes of that. The innocents who are persecuted by the apparatus of a great power. We know what the model is there. But what you have from about 1966-67 is not black people as suffering as the people who are being subjected to violence. But in the newspapers now you have stories about African Americans who are carrying out violence. So most obviously the rioters in the cities in 66, 67, but also you have younger activists now who say we have suffered enough. You know, the time for just meekly
他意识到了其中的圣经回响。那些被一个伟大机器的机构所迫害的无辜者。我们知道那里的原型是什么。但从1966到1967年前后，情况不再是黑人作为遭受暴力的受害者受苦受难，而是在报纸上，你开始看到关于非裔美国人实施暴力的报道。最明显的莫过于66年、67年城市里的暴动者，但同时你也有了更年轻的激进分子，他们说我们受够了。你知道，温顺游行的时代已经结束了。因此马尔科姆·X……
marching is over. And so Malcolm X. Well, Malcolm X has already been shot at this point, but Malcolm X is of course a trailblazer, a harbinger for this kind of thing. The Black Power slogan comes from a guy called Stokely Carmichael, a much younger activist. He is on a march through the South in the summer of 1966 and he starts chanting Black Power, Black Power. And younger, more militant activists are like at last.
好吧，马尔科姆·X此时已经遇刺身亡了，但马尔科姆·X当然是这方面的先驱和先兆。黑人权力（Black Power）这个口号来自于一个叫斯托克利·卡迈克尔（Stokely Carmichael）的人，他是一个年轻得多的激进分子。他在1966年夏天穿越南方的游行中开始高呼“黑人权力，黑人权力”。更年轻、更激进的激进分子则觉得：终于来了。
There's a generational issue here. King is an old man to them. I mean, he's not old to us, but he's old to them. And they say, finally, you know, somebody who's got a bit of backbone will stand up to the white establishment. And also they're quite cool, aren't they? The Black Panther. Well, this is the thing. I mean, there's all the Tom Wolf radical chic stuff. The white liberals as well, you know, they're quite edgy and yeah, bring them along to dinner parties and things.
这里存在一个代际问题。对他们来说，金是个老头子。我的意思是，对我们来说他不老，但对他们来说他老了。他们说，终于有个有点骨气的人站出来对抗白人建制派了。而且他们还挺酷的，不是吗？黑豹党。没错，就是这样。我的意思是，所有那些汤姆·沃尔夫式的“激进时髦”（radical chic）的东西。白人自由派也是，你知道的，他们挺有前卫感的，对，把他们带到晚宴上之类的地方。
Exactly. Exactly. So the Black Panthers really exposed onto the scene in the spring of 1967. People like Bobby Seale and Huey Newton, they have an armed invasion of the state capital in California, Sacramento. Huey Newton said, and I quote, political power comes to the barrel of a gun. We do not believe in passive and nonviolent tactics. They haven't worked for us black people. They are bankrupt. And do you think that, I mean, in the sixties, things are cool and you have to constantly be moving. You need new things by definition. If you stay with the old tried ways of doing things, you know, you're basically Cliff Richard. Yeah, you're square.
没错，没错。所以黑豹党在1967年春天真正轰动登场。像鲍比·希尔（Bobby Seale）和休伊·牛顿（Huey Newton）这样的人，他们在加州首府萨克拉门托对州议会大厦进行了武装突袭。休伊·牛顿说，我引用原话：“政治权力是从枪杆子里取得的。我们不相信消极和非暴力的策略。它们对我们黑人不管用。它们已经破产了。”你认为——我的意思是，在60年代，追求酷是很重要的，你必须不断前进。按定义你需要新鲜事物。如果你固守老一套的做事方式，你知道的，你基本上就是克里夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）。是的，你是个老古板。
You're square. Yeah. I mean, is that, is that a kind of part of the climate as well? I think it is. I absolutely think it is. So the student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee, SNCC as it is called, which has been such a big part of the civil rights movement in the South. The name is the Nonviolent Coordinating Committee. By 1967, its new chairman, who is a man called H.Rap Brown, he says, everybody should arm themselves and quote wage guerrilla war on the honky white man. Let's make the Viet Cong look like Sunday school teachers.
老古板。是的。我的意思是，这也是当时社会风气的一部分吗？我认为是的。我绝对认为是的。因此，学生非暴力协调委员会（SNCC），也就是人们所说的这个曾在南方的民权运动中发挥过如此巨大作用的组织。它的名字叫“非暴力协调委员会”。到了1967年，它的新主席，一个叫H·拉普·布朗（H. Rap Brown）的人，他说，每个人都应该武装自己，我引用原话：“对白鬼子发动游击战。我们要让越共看起来像主日学校老师一样温和。”
Groovy. I mean, this is exactly the kind of thing that seizes people's imagination. It is fashionable, frankly, in the late 1960s and Martin Luther King is regarded as yesterday's man. Have you ever written for the New York review of books, Tom? I haven't, no. Well, just as well, because they shame themselves at this point. They publish an article about Martin Luther King by a guy called Andrew Copkin, August 1967. King once had the ability
太时髦了。我的意思是，这正是那种能抓住人们想象力的东西。坦率地说，这在20世纪60年代末是非常时髦的，而马丁·路德·金则被视为过气人物。你给《纽约书评》写过稿子吗，汤姆？我没有，没有。好吧，这也罢，因为他们这时候真是在自取其辱。他们在1967年8月发表了一篇由安德鲁·科普金（Andrew Copkin）撰写的关于马丁·路德·金的文章，文中写道：“金曾经有能力
to talk to people, the power to change them. But the duty of a revolutionary is to make revolutions and King has made none. He has been outstripped by his times, overtaken by events which he may have obliquely helped to produce but could not predict. He has been outstripped by his times, overtaken by events which he may have obliquely helped to produce but could not predict. He's not likely to regain command." Kind of goodbye granddad. Right. I mean, it's kind of like, you know, this guy hasn't kept up with Sergeant Pepper or whatever. Exactly.
与人们对话，有改变他们的力量。但革命者的职责是发动革命，而金没有发动任何革命。他被他的时代抛弃了，被那些他可能间接推波助澜却无法预测的事件所超越。他被他的时代抛弃了，被那些他可能间接推波助澜却无法预测的事件所超越。他不太可能重新掌权。”有点像是“再见吧，爷爷”。没错。我的意思是，这有点像……你知道的，这家伙没有跟上《佩珀军士》（Sergeant Pepper）或者诸如此类的潮流。没错。
It's almost the same thing. You know, you've got to keep up with the vibe. Yeah. The fact that he has been outpaced by his times, that he hasn't produced results, black Americans are still likely to be poor, they're still likely to go to prison, all of this stuff. The time that nonviolence is over, the time that urgency has begun. That's basically what people are saying. And is Andrew Copkin black or white? He's white.
几乎是同一回事。你知道的，你得跟上时代的浪潮。是的。他被时代超越了，他没有产生结果，美国黑人依然很可能贫困，依然很可能进监狱，所有这些事情。非暴力运动的时代结束了，充满紧迫感的时代已经开始。这基本上就是人们在说的。而且安德鲁·科普金是黑人还是白人？他是白人。
He's a white radical journalist. Right. Okay. I mean, he's writing a bit like a white radical has to be said. He is indeed. He is. So King feels this pressure very, very deeply. If you think he has for more than a decade, he has been in the public eye. He's been long days.
他是一个白人激进记者。好。我的意思是，他写起东西来的确有点白人激进分子的腔调。他确实如此。确实如此。所以金非常、非常深刻地感受到了这种压力。如果你想想看，他已经进入公众视野十多年了。日子很长。
He's exhausted. He's been in prison 18 times. He has been punched in the face. He has been stabbed. He's been hit on the head with rocks. He's been tear gassed, sprayed with water cannons, had dogs set on him. All the time he is traveling, he's staying in kind of cheap hotels. This is a chilling precedent for us going on our tour of the United States, Tom.
他精疲力竭。他曾18次入狱。他的脸挨过拳头。他被刺伤过。他的头部被石头砸过。他中过催泪瓦斯，被水枪喷射过，被警犬撕咬过。他一直在旅行，住在各种廉价酒店里。这对我们去美国巡回演讲来说是一个令人不寒而栗的前车之鉴啊，汤姆。
I hope this doesn't happen to us, staying in cheap hotels. They're not quite so saintly. And I look at this, he's smoking and drinking too much, gaining weight, taking sleeping pills, constantly traveling, speaking and preaching. This is like you on tour, frankly. Yeah it is. Anyway, he's under enormous stress. His marriage is also crumbling by the way, because one of the things that people I guess now know about Martin Luther King is that he is a man, he's ravaged by guilt because he's not perfect. He's a sinner.
我希望我们不会遭遇这种事，住在廉价酒店里。他们可没那么圣洁。我看着他，他烟酒过度、体重增加、靠安眠药度日，不断地旅行、演讲和布道。坦率地说，这简直就像你在巡演一样。确实是这样。不管怎样，他承受着巨大的压力。顺便说一句，他的婚姻也正在崩溃，因为人们现在对马丁·路德·金的了解之一就是，他是一个饱受内疚折磨的人，因为他不完美。他是个罪人。
Yeah, he's a sinner. He has relationships outside his marriage. He confessed an affair to Coretta, his wife, over Christmas 1967. She was devastated, but she wasn't surprised. And she was, one of the things that devastated her was that actually he was in such a mess about it. He seemed, and I quote, terribly distressed. I had not seen him like this before. And also isn't he being hounded by the FBI and J. Edgar Hoover, who was kind of hoovering up scandalous details for his files and things like that. Yes. The FBI have had King under surveillance for years. J. Edgar Hoover tells LBJ, tells President Johnson in the course of 1967, that he's now convinced that King is quote, an
是的，他是个罪人。他在婚姻之外有婚外情。他在1967年圣诞节期间向妻子科雷塔坦白了一段婚外情。她崩溃了，但她并不感到惊讶。让她感到崩溃的原因之一实际上是，他对此陷入了极度混乱。他看起来——我引用原话——“极其痛苦。我以前没见过他这样。”而且难道他没有一直遭到联邦调查局（FBI）和J·埃德加·胡佛的纠缠吗？胡佛一直在为他的档案搜集丑闻细节等等。是的。联邦调查局对金进行多年的监视。J·埃德加·胡佛在1967年期间告诉LBJ（总统约翰逊），他现在确信金——我引用原话——是一个
instrument in the hands of subversive forces seeking to undermine our nation. He is absolutely obsessed with King's love life. A Tomcat with obsessive degenerative sexual urges, Jay Gohoover says of King. He has him taped with one of his lovers in Washington Hotel. The FBI then sends that tape to King's wife anonymously for her to listen to. So yes, he knows, I mean, King is not an idiot. He knows that the authorities are watching him the whole time, spying on him, spreading rumors about him to the newspapers. He is under immense, immense moral psychological pressure and his reaction to
企图颠覆我们国家的颠覆势力手中的工具。他对金的私生活有着绝对的痴迷。“一个有着强迫性退化性性冲动的花花公子，”J·埃德加·胡佛这样评价金。他在华盛顿的一家酒店里录下了金和他的一个情妇在一起的磁带。然后联邦调查局匿名将这卷磁带寄给金的妻子，让她听。所以是的，他知道——我的意思是，金不是傻瓜。他知道当局一直在监视他、窥探他，向报纸散布关于他的谣言。他承受着巨大无比的道德、心理压力，而他对
this actually, a lot of people say, okay, come on, as it were, wind your neck in, stop speaking out about these things, you know, go back to being the cuddly more moderate sort of moral prophet of talking about the South. But you use the word prophet and early you called him a secular saint. I mean, he is both, but ultimately he's a prophet in the biblical sense. He is inspired by the example of the biblical prophets who denounce injustice, but are themselves sinners. And that is, I mean, that's clearly what motivates him. It's what keeps him on the, on the trail, that sense of following in the line of Isaiah or Jeremiah or whatever. But it's also what gives him his enduring power. I mean, he is drawing on the rhythms and cadences
这一切的反应实际上是——许多人说：“行了吧，算了吧，收敛一点，别再谈论这些事情了，回到过去那种惹人喜爱、温和派的道德先知形象上去，去谈论南方吧。”但你用了“先知”这个词，早些时候你称他为“世俗圣人”。我的意思是，他两者皆是，但归根结底，他是《圣经》意义上的先知。他受到《圣经》先知们的榜样的启发，这些先知谴责不义，但他们自己也是罪人。这就是——我的意思是，这显然是激励他的动力。正是这种追随以赛亚或耶利米等人足迹的感觉，支撑着他继续在布道之路上前行。但这也是赋予他持久力量的源泉。我的意思是，他汲取了《圣经》先知们的韵律和
of the biblical prophets. And that is the journey to which he feels he is summoned. Yes, exactly so. And that is why he does not tack back towards the center. He feels that he has literally a God given duty to keep going. So he starts saying to people, you know, we need to go further. We need to have an, I quote, a revolution of values, complete moral surgery, radical redistribution of economic power. Of course, this is why the FBI are calling him a communist. He's not a communist. He's a biblical prophet.
节奏。这就是他感到自己受召召唤踏上的旅程。是的，完全如此。这就是为什么他没有向中间路线妥协。他觉得上帝赋予了他必须坚持下去的绝对职责。所以他开始对人们说，你知道的，我们需要走得更远。我们需要进行——我引用原话——“价值观的革命”、彻底的道德手术、对经济权力的彻底重新分配。当然，这就是为什么联邦调查局称他为共产党人。他不是共产主义者。他是一个《圣经》先知的化身。
Yeah. But he's also his politics are those of, you know, a sort of Western European democratic socialist. You know, what he's talking about is- I mean, practically that's the effect. Of course, the religious stuff, I totally agree with you. I mean, he is nothing if not a religious figure, Martin Luther King. He comes from the church. He's steeped in the church and in the values that his father, also a
是的。但他的政治立场也是那种……你知道的，某种西欧民主社会主义者的立场。他所谈论的是——从实际上来看，这就是效果。当然，宗教方面的内容，我完全同意你的看法。我的意思是，马丁·路德·金如果不是一个宗教人物的话，就什么都不是了。他出身于教会。他深深沉浸在教会以及他的父亲——同样是一位
preacher, had instilled in him. And partly because of this prophet thing, and again, to completely echo what you've been saying, at the end of 1967, he unveils his latest campaign, which is very kind of biblical. He says, I want to force America to confront the reality of poverty. And I want to have a massive demonstration in the heart of the capital of Washington, DC, it's going to be called the Poor People's Campaign. They will build a shanty town in the heart of Washington called Resurrection City, so it'll be in sight of the halls of the rich and powerful.
牧师——灌输给他的价值观念之中。部分由于这种“先知”的使命感，再次完全呼应你刚才所说的话，在1967年底，他推出了他的最新竞选活动，这非常有《圣经》色彩。他说：“我要迫使美国正视贫困的现实。我希望在华盛顿特区市中心发动一场大规模的示威活动，它将被称为‘穷人运动’。”他们将在华盛顿市中心建造一个名为“复活城”的棚户区，这样它就能进入那些富裕和权贵大厅的视野。
And he says we will have African-Americans, we will have native Americans, they're Indians, we'll have poor whites from Appalachia, we will have African-Americans, we will have native Americans, they're Indians. We'll have poor whites from Appalachia. We'll have Puerto Ricans. We'll have Pacific Islanders. We will have Eskimos. Have the works. Yeah.
他说，我们将有非裔美国人，我们将有美洲原住民——也就是印第安人，我们将有来自阿巴拉契亚的贫穷白人，我们将有非裔美国人，我们将有美洲原住民，也就是印第安人。我们将有来自阿巴拉契亚的贫穷白人。我们将有波多黎各人。我们将有太平洋岛民。我们将有爱斯基摩人。应有尽有。对。
We will have the most marginalized people in the United States and we will bring them to the Capitol. So it's Lazarus at the gates of Deves. It is. Now, the thing is, lots of people in it, as allies say, this is a really bad idea. What will happen if it all goes wrong? What will happen if there's violence? We will get the blame, you will get the blame and you will damage our cause.
我们将动员美国最被边缘化的人群，把他们带到国会山。所以这就是拉撒路站在富人门前的翻版。确实如此。问题是，里面的许多人，比如助手们都说，这是一个非常糟糕的主意。如果一切搞砸了会怎么样？如果发生暴力事件会怎么样？我们会受到指责，你会受到指责，并且你会损害我们的事业。
The establishments are very different from the Martyr in Washington in 1963. The establishments of course have been very suspicious of that as well, but Kennedy and Co. eventually grudgingly come round to it. It's the first time Kennedy watches Martin Luther King speak, isn't it, at that? Yeah. And says, my God, he's good. But this time it is clear the authorities will not cooperate at all.
当时的建制派与1963年华盛顿大游行时的建制派非常不同。当然，当时的建制派对那次游行也非常怀疑，但肯尼迪及其幕僚最终勉强接受了。那是肯尼迪第一次看马丁·路德·金演讲，对吧？是的。并且说：“天哪，他讲得真好。”但这一次，很显然，当局根本不会配合。
In fact, the FBI are making plans to undermine it. And so as 1968 begins, King is all devoted to this poor people's campaign, but his aides are very worried you know, worried about it. He's under all this pressure from the authorities about it. And then he gets an invitation to come to Memphis, Tennessee. So Memphis has not really featured in the civil rights story to this point. It's on the banks of the Mississippi. It's a tough town, Memphis. It had once been one of the biggest slave markets in the South run by the founder of the Ku Klux Klan, General Nathan Bedford Forrest.
事实上，联邦调查局正在制定计划来破坏它。因此，随着1968年的开始，金把所有的精力都投入到了这场“穷人运动”中，但他的助手们非常担心，你知道的，对此忧心忡忡。他正承受着来自当局的巨大压力。就在这时，他收到了前往田纳西州孟菲斯的邀请。因此，孟菲斯此前并未真正出现在民权故事中。它位于密西西比河畔。孟菲斯是一个艰难的城市。它曾是南方最大的奴隶市场之一，由三K党创始人内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特将军经营。
Memphis had become a magnet for migrants from the countryside in the early 20th century, this is where you get the blues. Yeah. So Beale Street, the home of the blues in Memphis, all these clubs. But most people of course were not blues musicians. They are janitors. They are waiters, they're cooks. They're very poorly treated, poorly paid. And maids.
20世纪初，孟菲斯成为了吸引乡村移民的磁石，这也是布鲁斯音乐（蓝调）的诞生地。是的。所以比尔街（Beale Street）——孟菲斯的蓝调发源地，所有这些俱乐部。但大多数人当然不是蓝调音乐家。他们是门房。他们是服务员、厨师。他们受到极坏的对待，薪水极低。还有女佣。
And maids, yes. Some of whom are working in for Elvis. Yeah, I guess that's right. Yes. Who at this very moment is busy plotting his comeback in Graceland. Nice to get Elvis onto the show, Tom. Well, but this is what's so fascinating about the politics of the United States in this period is that the popular culture is so rich and it's not just, I think, kind of extraneous. It is part of the climate of opinion.
还有女佣，是的。其中一些人还在为埃尔维斯（猫王）工作。是的，我想是的。是的。而此时此刻，他正忙着在格雷斯兰（Graceland）策划他的复出。很高兴能在节目中提到埃尔维斯，汤姆。好吧，但这就是这一时期美国政治如此迷人之处，大众文化是如此丰富，而且我认为这不仅仅是某种外在的东西。它是当时舆论气候的一部分。
I completely agree. It's not just as it were literally the soundtrack, but it's also a kind of metaphorical soundtrack for everything that is happening. Yeah. And I mean Elvis' comeback, there's a slight kind of mix and soundtrack for everything that is happening. Yeah. And I mean Elvis' comeback, there's a slight kind of Nixon parallel there as well, do you think? I tell you what, there's a great podcast in Elvis and Nixon and their tangled relationship.
我完全同意。它不仅是——字面意义上的配乐，它也是正在发生的一切的一种隐喻性配乐。是的。我的意思是，埃尔维斯的复出，你觉得这其中跟尼克松也有点微妙的平行关系吗？我告诉你，关于埃尔维斯和尼克松以及他们纠缠不清的关系，可以出一期很棒的播客。
Well he'll get a badge from Nixon, won't he? He will indeed. So what happened in Memphis was this. On the 1st of February, two men who were, we would call them rubbish collectors, bin men in Britain, they are killed in their own rubbish truck. They are pulled in by the machinery and crushed to death. And they made very little money.
好吧，他会从尼克松那里得到一个徽章，不是吗？他确实会。所以孟菲斯发生的事情是这样的。2月1日，两名在英国我们称之为垃圾收集工、在美国叫垃圾工的男子，在他们自己的垃圾车里丧生了。他们被卷入机械中被压路机碾压致死。他们的收入微乎其微。
The city gave them no benefits, no pensions, anything like that. Their widows are left destitute. And after that, about one and a half thousand employees from the city's sanitation, sewer and drainage departments go on strike. They want union recognition. They want better pay, better hours, all of these kinds of things. It's a very, you might say a very mundane campaign, but a very important one for those people. You know, it's unglamorous, but for these people, I mean, it really matters.
城市没有给他们任何福利、养老金之类的东西。他们的遗孀一贫如洗。在那之后，该市环卫、下水道和排水部门的大约一千五百名员工举行了罢工。他们要求获得工会承认。他们想要更好的薪水、更好的工作时间，所有这些事情。你可能会说这是一场非常世俗、平凡的运动，但对那些人来说却至关重要。你知道，它并不光鲜亮丽，但对这些人来说，我的意思是，这真的非常重要。
They are almost all black. So there's a definite racial side to this. The city authorities are white, the strikers are black. And a Memphis minister who is an old friend of King's called James Lawson, he'd been a nonviolent campaigner, he'd been to India, all of this stuff. He takes up this cause and he says, we should make this a civil rights crusade. And he goes to the striking workers, sanitation workers, and he says, you are human beings, you deserve dignity, you're not a slave, you are a man.
他们几乎全都是黑人。所以这里有着明确的种族因素。市政府当局是白人，罢工者是黑人。孟菲斯的一位牧师、金的老朋友詹姆斯·劳森（James Lawson）——他曾是一名非暴力活动家，去过印度，经历丰富——接手了这一事业。他说，我们应该把这变成一场民权十字军东征。他去找那些罢工的环卫工人，对他们说：“你们是人，你们配得上尊严，你们不是奴隶，你们是顶天立地的男子汉。”
And that becomes their slogan. I am a man. And so this guy Lawson, he rings Martin Luther King in March, 17th of March. And he says, look, we've got this strike in Memphis, nobody cares, it's not really making the news nationwide because it's so unglamorous. Our men are being attacked by the police with clubs. This feels to me very like what you're trying to do with your Poor People's Campaign.
这句话成了他们的口号：我是一个男人（I am a man）。所以这个叫劳森的人在3月17日给马丁·路德·金打电话。他说：“听着，我们在孟菲斯有这样一场罢工，没人关心，它没有真正登上全国新闻，因为它太不起眼了。我们的工人正遭到警察的棍棒袭击。我觉得这非常像你试图通过‘穷人运动’去做的事情。”
Yeah, because the very fact that it's rubbish, that it's filth, that it's trash. I mean, that's the whole point, isn't it? Exactly. Take this incredibly unglamorous cause, the cause of the gutter and make it your own. And King says, sure, I'm going to the South anyway, tomorrow. I'll come and see you. Now King's staff already think he's massively overworked. What really? Another one?
是的，因为这正是垃圾、污秽、废弃物本身的含义。我的意思是，这正是全部的要点，不是吗？没错。把这个极其不光彩的事业——阴沟里的事业——拿过来，让它成为你自己的事业。金说：“当然，我明天就要去南方了。我会去见你们的。”现在，金的团队已经认为他严重过度劳累了。什么？真的吗？又来一个？
Yeah. He says, of course I'm going to do it. He flies to Memphis the next day, the 18th of March, and he goes straight to this black Pentecostal church called the Mason temple. There are 15,000 people there. He speaks without notes. He gives another of these brilliant speeches. I love this one. I absolutely love this one. Do you want to read it, Tom?
是的。他说：“我当然会去。”他第二天——3月18日——飞往孟菲斯，径直去了这座名为梅森圣殿（Mason Temple）的黑人五旬节派教堂。那里有1万5千人。他没有看讲稿。他又发表了一场精彩绝伦的演讲。我喜欢这一场。我绝对喜欢这一场。你想读一下吗，汤姆？
Well, so I'm just looking at the context that you've given it. Mason temple, massive black Pentecostal church, huge turnout, 15,000 people there. And he speaks without notes and the spirit descends on him. Clearly he speaks with fire and he's talking about the struggle for equality, which he says means economic equality. And this famous line, what does it profit a man to be able to eat at an integrated lunch counter if he doesn't earn enough money to buy a cup of coffee? But then it goes quality. And this famous line, what does it profit a man to be able to eat at an integrated lunch counter if he doesn't earn enough money to buy a cup of coffee? But then it goes beyond that. He talks about what the United States is doing and generally what humanity is doing, what capitalist society is capable of achieving. And there are absolute echoes of Marx here,
好的，我正看着你给它的背景。梅森圣殿，巨大的黑人五旬节教堂，空前盛况，有15,000人在场。他没有看讲稿，精神力量降临在他身上。显然，他充满激情地演讲，谈到对平等的奋斗，他认为这意味着经济平等。还有这句名言：“一个人如果买不起一杯咖啡，能够在一个种族融合的小吃柜台吃东西，这对他有什么好处呢？”但随后它超越了这一点。他谈到了美国在做什么，以及整个人类在做什么，资本主义社会能够取得什么成就。这里绝对有马克思的迴响，
I think, but I think that in both cases, both King and Marx are echoing biblical themes, whether consciously or not. We build gigantic buildings to kiss the sky and gargantuan bridges to span the seas. Through our spaceships, we carve highways through the stratosphere. So it's the year before the moon landing. Through our submarines, we penetrate oceanic depths. But it seems I can hear the God of the universe saying, even though you've done all of that, I was hungry and you fed me not, I was naked and you clothed me not, so you cannot enter the kingdom of greatness. And even reading that, I feel a shiver down
我想，但我认为在这两种情况下，金和马克思都在呼应《圣经》的主题，无论是有意还是无意。我们建造巨大的建筑去亲吻天空，建造宏伟的桥梁横跨海洋。通过我们的宇宙飞船，我们在平流层中开辟高速公路。所以这是登月的前一年。通过我们的潜水艇，我们深入海洋的深处。但似乎我能听到宇宙之神在说：“尽管你们完成了所有这一切，但我饿了，你们没有给我饭吃，我赤身露体，你们没有给我衣服穿，所以你们不能进入伟大的王国。”甚至在阅读这段话时，我都感到脊背发凉。
the spine. I mean, it is so powerful. To hear him say that, I mean, it must have been amazing. Just unbelievable. Yeah, I agree completely. And the atmosphere, electric, people shouting, you know, amen, hallelujah, say it, all of that kind of stuff. That's it. The call and response side of these kind of African American church services, which makes it all the more exciting and electric to be there, I think. And he's buoyed, as you said, the spirit has descended. He's buoyed by the response of the electric to be there, I think. And he's buoyed, as you said, the spirit has descended. He's buoyed by the response of the crowd and he says, I'm going to come back to Memphis.
我的意思是，它是如此充满力量。听他亲口说出这些话，我的意思是，那一定太惊人了。简直难以置信。是的，我完全同意。那里的气氛充满电流，人们在呐喊，你知道的，“阿门”、“哈利路亚”、“说得好”，所有这些。就是这样。这种非洲裔美国人教堂礼拜中呼应互动的形式，让身临其境变得更加激动人心和充满张力，我想是的。而且他受到了鼓舞，正如你所说，圣灵已经降临。他受到人群反应的鼓舞，并说：“我还要回到孟菲斯来。”
I will lead a march through the city. I want all of you to join me with your families and your children. And there are people shouting and clapping and cheering and crying. His staff who are there are standing in a kind of grim silence. This is awful. Like another event in the schedule, yet more pressure. Memphis is not a very Martin Luther King friendly town. This is a bad idea. However, he goes back that night to the usual place that he stays and we should just talk about this because it's really important. He stays in a motel called the Lorraine Motel. It's in the southern end of downtown, not far from the river. It's the place where it's a black
我将带领一场游行穿过这座城市。我希望你们所有人都能带着家人和孩子加入我。人们在呐喊、鼓掌、欢呼、哭泣。现场他的工作人员则以一种冷酷的沉默伫立着。这太糟糕了。就像日程表上的又一个活动，带来更多的压力。孟菲斯可不是一个对马丁·路德·金很友好的小镇。这是个糟糕的主意。然而，那天晚上他回到了他常住的地方——我们真得谈谈这个，因为这非常重要。他住在一个叫洛林汽车旅馆的汽车旅馆里。它位于市中心的南端，离河不远。这是一个黑人
family owned and blues and gospel stars when they come to Memphis always stay there. So Ray Charles has stayed there, Louis Armstrong has stayed there, Aretha Franklin has stayed there. King has been many times and the owners let him stay for free. He always stays in one particular room, room 306 on the second floor. And if you look at photos of the motel, it's very sort of mid sixties modern, kind of mid century modern. It's quite simple, a little bit Scandi, a bit Ikea you could say, you know, the room with the little TV, all of that kind of thing. So that's where he is. That's where he always goes. Now the next day, the next few days, he goes off to the Mississippi Delta, which is part of his Poor People's Campaign.
家族经营的地方，布鲁斯和福音音乐明星来到孟菲斯时总是住在那里。所以雷·查尔斯住过那里，路易斯·阿姆斯特朗住过那里，艾瑞莎·富兰克林也住过那里。金去过很多次，老板让他免费入住。他总是住在同一个特定的房间，二楼的306房间。如果你看这家汽车旅馆的照片，它非常具有六十年代中期现代主义的风格，有点像世纪中期现代主义。非常简单，有点斯堪的纳维亚风格，可以说有点像宜家，你知道的，那个带有小电视的房间，诸如此类。所以他就在那里。那是他总是去的地方。第二天，接下来的几天里，他去了密西西比三角洲，那是他穷人运动的一部分。
One of the poorest places in North America. You know, the sodden cotton fields, the shacks. A place absolutely haunted by the ghosts of slavery. So he's off in Mississippi and he's waiting to come back to Memphis for this march that he's promised. But there's a series of freak snow storms. What? I know. Unbelievable. Snow storms?
北美最贫困的地方之一。你知道的，湿漉漉的棉田，简陋的小屋。一个绝对被奴役的幽灵所萦绕的地方。所以他去了密西西比，正等待着回到孟菲斯参加他承诺过的这场游行。但却发生了一系列罕见的暴风雪。什么？我知道。难以置信。暴风雪？
Yeah. I didn't know they had that in the South. They do. Wow. Who knew? So there's been a lot of snow and the March is postponed and postponed and is finally rescheduled for Thursday, the 28th of March, 1968. March 28th, as they would say.
对。我不知道南方也有这玩意儿。确实有。哇。谁能想到呢？所以下了很多雪，游行被一次又一次地推迟，最后重新安排在1968年3月28日星期四。正如他们所说，3月28日。
March 28th exactly. But a spoiler alert, it will turn out very differently from what Martin Luther King is expecting. Okay. Well, we will find out how, just how differently after the break. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and we are in Memphis. It's the 28th of May or May 28th if you're American. It's Thursday and Martin Luther King, Dominic, is about to lead this much anticipated march in aid of the trash and refuse workers through the streets of Memphis. Yes, and unfortunately the march is a complete and utter catastrophe for Memphis, for King himself, for the image of his campaign. So we talked in the first half about this sense of how he'd lost
确切地说是3月28日。但剧透一下，事情的发展将与马丁·路德·金所期望的截然不同。好吧。嗯，中场休息后，我们会知道究竟有多么不同。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History），我们在孟菲斯。今天是5月28日，如果你是美国人的话就是May 28th。今天是星期四，多米尼克，马丁·路德·金正准备在孟菲斯街头领导这场备受期待的、旨在帮助环卫和垃圾工人的游行。是的，不幸的是，对孟菲斯、对金本人、对他的运动形象而言，这场游行是一场彻底的灾难。所以我们在前半部分谈到了这种感觉，即他是如何失去
control of, or was losing control of his movement, that there's a generation gap in the movement, there are people who are calling for greater urgency or this kind of thing. And you see this, you know, made manifest in the streets of Memphis. Because when he gets there, he is horrified to find out that it's not the family friendly, you know, march of women and children or whatnot that he used to lead in the deep south in the late 1950s, early 1960s. There are loads of teenagers, there are people drinking, there are people shouting about black power, there were very aggressive placards about sort of taking the struggle against
对运动的控制，或者正在失去控制，运动中存在代沟，有人在呼吁更大的紧迫感或诸如此类的事情。你在孟菲斯的街头看到了这一点，它具象化了。因为当他到达那里时，他惊恐地发现，这并不是他习惯于在20世纪50年代末、60年代初的深南部领导的那种由妇女和儿童组成的、适合家庭的游行。这里有大量的青少年，有人在喝酒，有人在叫喊黑人权力，还有非常激进的标语，关于把抗争提升到
the whites, all of this kind of thing. And he seriously thinks, he's utterly downcast and he seriously thinks about cancelling the march. And then he decides, no, the best thing is probably to go ahead anyway. They go ahead with the march through Memphis, which is already suffering the kind of urban blight that will become such a feature of American life in the 1970s and 80s. So they're marching through these kind of dilapidated streets, bordered up shops, all of this kind of thing.
针对白人的层面，诸如此类。他认真地考虑——他感到无比沮丧，并认真考虑取消游行。然后他决定，不，最好的办法可能还是继续进行。他们继续在孟菲斯进行游行，这里已经饱受城市衰败之苦，这种衰败将在20世纪70年代和80年代成为美国生活的一个特征。所以他们走在这些破败的街道上，木板封住的店铺，所有这些景象中。
There was a lot of pushing and shoving behind him. He's very conscious of this. They get onto Beale Street, which is the home of the blues. Once a great destination, now a lot of the clubs have moved out. It feels shabby and seedy and depressing. It's about this point that the violence starts. People start smashing shop windows. They're looting.
他身后有很多推搡。他对此非常清楚。他们走上了毕尔盛街，那是布鲁斯的发源地。曾经是一个伟大的目的地，现在许多俱乐部都搬走了。它让人感觉破旧、肮脏、压抑。正是在这个时候，暴力开始了。人们开始砸碎商店窗户。他们在进行抢劫。
They're throwing bottles and bricks at the police. The police start to wade in. It all kicks off. King and his allies are ushered away for their own safety by the police to a hotel, the Holiday Inn, which is a brand new high rise luxury hotel. That's an important detail, which we'll come back to. So he's in a hotel room there and he's watching what's happening on TV. And he is horrified because it is absolutely kicking off in Memphis.
他们向警察投掷瓶子和砖头。警察开始介入。情况全面失控。金和他的盟友为了自身安全被警察护送到一家酒店，假日酒店，这是一家崭新的高层豪华酒店。这是一个重要的细节，我们稍后会回到这一点。所以他在那里的一个酒店房间里，看着电视上发生的事情。他感到惊恐万状，因为孟菲斯的情况彻底失控了。
The authorities call for the national guard, the police chief goes on TV and he says, this is a civil war. It's a local civil war. And King, this is one of the low points in his entire life. He's just standing there watching this on TV. Because the violence is coming from the marches as well as from the police this time. So it's upended his strategy. It has completely. This is not, you know, Alabama policemen wading in against defenseless
当局呼吁国民警卫队出动，警察局长上电视说，这是一场内战。这是一场地方内战。对于金来说，这是他一生中的低谷之一。他只是站在那里看着电视上的这一切。因为这一次暴力既来自游行者，也来自警察。所以这颠覆了他的策略。彻底颠覆了。这不，你知道的，不是阿拉巴马州的警察殴打毫无防御能力的
women and children. These are black teenagers fighting back, looting stores, throwing things at the police. And the sense that the violence has come from the march. It's not been directed at the march. It is the march that has created the violence. And he's ringing his advisors. He says to one of them, I know what the press will say. They will say, and I quote, Martin Luther King is dead. He is finished. His nonviolence is nothing.
妇女和儿童。这些是进行反击、抢劫商店、向警察投掷物品的黑人青少年。并且这种暴力源于游行本身的感观。它不是针对游行而发起的。正是游行制造了暴力。他给他的顾问打电话。他对其中一个人说，我知道媒体会怎么说。他们会说，我引用原话，马丁·路德·金死了。他完了。他的非暴力毫无意义。
No one is listening to it. And that night he can't sleep. He's with his greatest friend, his greatest ally, another minister called Ralph Abernathy. And he says to him, you know, this country is sick. Maybe we should just give up and let it sink into its sickness. Maybe violence is what people want because they're not listening to us. The next day he wakes up such as he can because he's hardly had any sleep and he looks at the next day's papers and they are terrible. And part of this is because the FBI has been fueling the criticism of Martin Luther King
没有人听他的。那天晚上他无法入睡。他和他最伟大的朋友、最伟大的盟友、另一位名叫拉尔夫·阿伯纳西的牧师在一起。他对他说，你知道，这个国家病了。也许我们应该放弃，让它沉沦于自身的疾病中。也许暴力正是人们想要的，因为他们不听我们的。第二天，他勉强醒来，因为他几乎没怎么合眼，他看了第二天的报纸，报纸上的内容糟透了。部分原因是因为联邦调查局（FBI）一直在煽动对马丁·路德·金的批评
and they have told everybody this hypocrite, this sinner, this liar and fraud. Do you know where he is? He's in a luxury hotel. He led this march, it all kicked off and then he went up to his suite and he's swanning around with his friends in this fancy white-owned hotel. He led this march, it all kicked off and then he went up to his suite and he's swanning around with his friends in this fancy white-owned hotel. And King is devastated by this and it's really important because it means that the next time he comes to Memphis he will definitely stay at his favorite place, the Lorraine Motel, no matter what the risks because it is important to him to prove that he's not a hypocrite.
他们告诉所有人，这个伪君子，这个罪人，这个骗子和诈骗犯。你知道他在哪儿吗？他在一家豪华酒店里。他领导了这场游行，结果全面失控，然后他回到了自己的套房，在这个由白人拥有的高级酒店里和他的朋友们招摇过市。他领导了这场游行，结果全面失控，然后他回到了自己的套房，在这个由白人拥有的高级酒店里和他的朋友们招摇过市。金对此感到心碎，这非常重要，因为这意味着他下次来孟菲斯时，无论冒多大风险，他都一定会住在自己最喜欢的地方——洛林汽车旅馆，因为向世人证明自己不是伪君子对他来说至关重要。
So on Saturday the 30th of March, King flew back to Atlanta and he met the leaders of his kind of Southern Christian leadership conventional conference or something. That's right. And they all say to him, look, that was an absolute disaster. Please don't go back to Memphis, whatever you do. This is not, you know, your poor people's campaign is probably not a very good idea, but this Memphis trash workers business is terrible. And he is very upset at this. He's visibly upset. And he says,
所以在3月30日星期四（注：原文误记为周六，此处按原文翻译），金飞回了亚特兰大，并会见了南方基督教领袖会议之类的组织的领导人。没错。他们都对他说，听着，那绝对是一场灾难。无论如何请不要再回孟菲斯了。这不是，你知道的，你们的穷人运动可能不是个好主意，但孟菲斯这个垃圾工人的事太糟糕了。他对此非常沮丧。他情绪显而易见地低落。他说，
if I can't go to Memphis, then I can't go anywhere. Like, what's the point if I can't go somewhere like that and stand up for these people? They still don't agree. And he actually does something he's never really done before. He storms out in a fury. Biographers have pored over the details of that afternoon. What, where did he go? Did he go to see his father? Did he go to see one of his lovers?
如果我不能去孟菲斯，那我哪里也去不了。就像，如果我不能去那样的地方为这些人挺身而出，那还有什么意义？他们仍然不同意。而他做了一件他以前从未真正做过的事。他愤怒地冲了出去。传记作家们仔细研究了那天下午的细节。什么，他去哪儿了？他是去见他父亲了吗？他是去见他的某个情人了吗？
Did he just go and pray? We don't know. But in his absence, all the other people, a lot of him, of course, are ministers too, are so shocked and upset that he has stormed out. They say, we will do anything to bring him back and to please him. Fine. We will make this work. We'll go with this poor people's campaign and we'll go with the Memphis thing.
还是他只是去祈祷了？我们不知道。但在他不在的时候，其他人——当然其中很多人也是牧师——对他的拂袖而去感到如此震惊和沮丧。他们说，我们愿意做任何事来把他带回来，让他高兴。好吧。我们会让这事成功的。我们会支持这个穷人运动，也会支持孟菲斯的事情。
So he comes back and he is delighted by this. But of course, King being King, his diary makes yours look like blank pages with nothing happening Tom, which is saying something because he has to rush off immediately to Washington because the next day he's going to be preaching at the Washington National Cathedral. And this is his last formal sermon of his life on Sunday the 31st of March. It's a sign of how much he's doubling down on the radicalism. He talks about Vietnam in the sermon in Washington. He says one of the most unjust wars in the history of the world.
所以他回来了，对此感到高兴。但当然，作为金，他的日程表让你的日程表看起来就像是一片空白、什么都没发生一样，汤姆。这可真说明问题，因为他不得不立刻赶往华盛顿，因为第二天他要在华盛顿国家大教堂讲道。这是他3月31日星期日生命中的最后一次正式布道。这表明他在激进主义道路上加倍投入了多少。他在华盛顿的布道中谈到了越南。他说这是世界历史上最不公正的战争之一。
He also doubles down on his poor people's campaign. America has not met her obligations to the poor. You know, I'm going to go through with this. So he gives this sermon. And then afterwards, he's surrounded by the press. The press are asking him actually about the election. Who is he going to support? And he says, well, I cannot support president Johnson.
他还加倍推行他的穷人运动。美国没有履行对穷人的义务。你知道的，我要把这件事情进行到底。所以他发表了这篇布道。然后在那之后，他被记者包围了。记者实际上在问他关于大选的事。他将支持谁？他说，嗯，我不能支持约翰逊总统。
I will not support him. I could consider either Eugene McCarthy or Robert Kennedy. What he doesn't know at that point is that just hours later, Oh, it's the very night. The very night Johnson is going to go on television, pull out to the presidential race. God, it is all happening, isn't it? It is all happening at once. All these things, that's the amazing thing about 1968. It's all happening at once. So then a couple of days go by and four days later, the 3rd of April,
我不会支持他。我可以考虑尤金·麦卡锡或罗伯特·肯尼迪。他当时并不知道，仅仅几个小时后——哦，就是当晚。就在当晚，约翰逊将要发表电视讲话，退出总统竞选。天哪，这一切都在发生，不是吗？这一切都在同时发生。所有这些事情，这就是1968年神奇的地方。所有事情都在同时发生。接着几天过去了，四天后的4月3日，
he and Ralph Abernathy, his great pal, fly to Memphis. There's a bomb scare, there's death threats. He's getting death threats all the time, but he's probably never had so many as he's getting now. There's a bomb scare, the plane, whole plane has to be searched, the luggage unloaded and searched for explosives. And then they're given the go ahead. They fly and they land in Memphis at about 1030 and they go straight to the
他和他的好哥们拉尔夫·阿伯纳西飞往孟菲斯。有炸弹恐吓，有死亡威胁。他一直在收到死亡威胁，但可能从来没有像现在这样收到这么多。有炸弹恐吓，飞机，整架飞机都必须接受搜查，卸下行李并搜查爆炸物。然后他们得到了放行的许可。他们起飞并于10点30分左右降落在孟菲斯，然后直奔
Lorraine Motel to his usual room, room 306. And he goes to this guy Lawson, the guy who brought him to Memphis. They go to his church, Methodist church to discuss the plans for their next march. Lawson says, well, there's bad news. The city authorities have got an injunction to stop the march. Our lawyers are working on it. They think they can reverse an injunction to stop the march. Our lawyers are working on it. They think they can reverse it, but they will need time. For now, we just have to kind of kick our heels for a day or two. King says, yeah, fine, whatever. He goes back to the Lorraine
洛林汽车旅馆，去他常住的306房间。他去找了这个人，劳森，那个把他带到孟菲斯的人。他们去了劳森的教堂，卫理公会教堂，讨论他们下次游行的计划。劳森说，嗯，有个坏消息。市政府当局已经获得了一项禁令来阻止游行。我们的律师正在处理此事。他们认为他们可以推翻阻止游行的禁令。我们的律师正在处理此事。他们认为他们可以推翻它，但这需要时间。目前，我们只能闲待一两天。金说，好吧，行，随便。他回到了洛林
Hotel. He's feeling exhausted. He's shattered. He feels ill. There's a storm coming, literally a huge storm is building over the town. He is supposed to speak that evening at the Mason temple, this huge kind of Pentecostal church where he'd given this amazing speech. And he says to Ralph Abernathy, I can't face going out in the storm. I'm absolutely exhausted. Would you consider doing it?" And Abanathi goes to the church and then he rings him at the motel and says, Martin, I don't know what to say. Nobody wants to hear from me. They want you. Is there any way you could come? And King says, fine, I'll come. So nine o'clock he arrives at this church. The rain is pouring down this thunder overhead. It's a kind of quite apocalyptic, you know, very dramatic scene.
酒店。他感到精疲力竭。他累垮了。他感觉生病了。一场风暴即将来临，字面意义上一场巨大的风暴正在小镇上空酝酿。他本计划那天晚上在梅森圣殿发表演讲，这是一座巨大的五旬节派教堂，他曾在这里发表过精彩的演讲。他对拉尔夫·阿伯纳西说，我无法面对在风暴中外出。我简直筋疲力尽。你会考虑代我去吗？”阿伯纳西去了教堂，然后从汽车旅馆给他打电话说，马丁，我不知道该说什么。没人想听我讲。他们想要你。你有什么办法能来吗？金说，好吧，我去。于是九点钟他到达了这座教堂。大雨倾盆，头顶雷声轰鸣。这是一种相当末日般的、非常戏剧性的场景。
Well you might say it's a bit like God thundering forth from the summit of Sinai. It is. Well the summit of Sinai, the mountaintop analogy, Tom, very well chosen. King stands up, he has no notes again. He has to raise his voice to be heard above the thunder and the rain sort of hammering on the roof of the church. And at first he seems very exhausted and he says, the nation is sick, you know, there's trouble in the land. And then he says, however, people are rising up and their cry across the world is the same, we want to be free.
嗯，你可能会说这有点像上帝从西奈山之巅雷霆万钧。确实如此。嗯，西奈山之巅，山顶的比喻，汤姆，选得真好。金站起身来，他依然没有带稿子。他不得不提高嗓门，以便压过雷声和雨水敲打教堂屋顶的声音。起初他看起来非常疲惫，他说，这个国家病了，你知道的，这片土地上有麻烦。然后他说，然而，人们正在奋起，他们遍布世界的呐喊是一样的，我们渴望自由。
And he goes on and goes on. And then you're very good at this, Tom, so why don't you do it? The famous climax of the speech, I have to say we've done hundreds of episodes and all this. I find this so moving. Some of the most moving stuff we've ever done on the rest is history. So I mentioned Moses climbing Sinai and Moses, of course, is the great prophet who leads his people out of slavery towards the promised land, but Moses himself is not allowed to enter
他接着说下去，接着说下去。然后你很擅长这个，汤姆，所以你为什么不来呢？演讲著名的最高潮，我必须说我们做过几百期节目以及诸如此类。我觉得这太感人了。这是我们在《历史其余部分》中做过的最感人的内容之一。所以我提到了摩西登上西奈山，而摩西，当然，是带领他的民众走出奴役、走向应许之地的伟大先知，但摩西本人是不被允许进入
the promised land. But God allows him just before he dies to go up to Mount Nebo and from the summit of Mount Nebo to gaze out over the promised land. And that is the context for this very, very famous speech, the great climax of it. And King says, and imagine that as Dominic, you were saying, the thunder, the rain hammering down on the roof, we've got some difficult days ahead, but it really doesn't matter with me now because I've been to the mountaintop. The mountaintop is Mount Nebo in his mind. And I don't mind, like anybody, I would like to live a long life, but I'm not concerned about that now. I just want to do God's will. And he's allowed me to go up to the mountain and I've looked over and I've seen the promised land.
应许之地的。但上帝允许他在死前登上尼波山，从尼波山的山顶眺望应许之地。这就是这篇非常、非常著名的演讲的背景，它的伟大高潮。金说，想象一下，正如多米尼克你所说的那样，雷声、雨水敲打着屋顶，我们前方有一些艰难的日子，但这对我来说现在真的无所谓了，因为我曾登上山顶。他心中的山顶就是尼波山。我不在乎，像任何人一样，我想过上长寿的生活，但我现在不关心这个。我只想遵行上帝的意志。他允许我登上山，我眺望远方，我看到了应许之地。
I may not get there with you, but I want you to know tonight that we as a people will get to the promised land. So I'm happy tonight. I'm not worried about anything. I'm not fearing any man. My eyes have seen the glory of the coming of the Lord. I mean, wow. That is, the speech itself is so powerful. It's drawing on all these biblical echoes, the sense of people coming from slavery into redemption. But of course, the context also is everything. Of course. And if you listen to the recording, which you can hear on YouTube, it is incredible stuff because of the atmosphere, because there are people shouting, because he's having to raise his voice because of the storm. There are people encouraging him. They're shouting
我可能无法与你们一同到达那里，但我今晚想让你们知道，我们作为一个民族将会到达应许之地。所以我今晚很高兴。我什么都不担心。我不惧怕任何人。我的眼睛看到了主降临的荣耀。我的意思是，哇。那是，演讲本身太有力量了。它汲取了所有这些圣经的回音，人们从奴役走向救赎的感受。当然，背景也决定了一切。当然。如果你听录音——你可以在YouTube上听到——那是令人难以置信的内容，因为那种氛围，因为人们在呐喊，因为他因为风暴不得不提高嗓门。人们在鼓励他。他们在高喊
out, amen, tell it Martin, all of this kind of stuff. And he does. But we've been talking about him as a prophet. God speaks to Moses on the mountaintop, on Mount Nebo. And he says, I have caused thee to see it with thine eyes, but thou shalt not go over thither. You know, you have led people this far, you will go no further. And what is coming Dominic? What is coming? Well, at the end of the speech, he collapses, almost exhausted.
阿门，说得好，马丁，诸如此类的话。他确实这么做了。但我们一直在谈论他作为先知的事。上帝在山顶、在尼波山上对摩西说话。他说，我使你亲眼看见了，你却不得过河去。你知道的，你已经把人们带到了这里，你不会再前进了。多米尼克，接下来会发生什么？接下来会发生什么？嗯，在演讲结束时，他几乎筋疲力竭地瘫倒了。
Remember, he didn't want to go because he was so tired and to Abanath his arms and there are people crying all around him and whatnot. And he goes back to the Ray Motel that night and people said at the time he seemed liberated. It was, he was giddy, you know, boyish having done the speech. He has dinner with his staff at the motel. And then here is, here is the human being, right? The man of flesh and blood. He almost certainly spent that evening with his mistress, Georgia Davis, who was a state senator from Kentucky, who had come to spend the night with him. And she was well known in his circle. Nobody was surprised at this.
记住，他因为太累而不想去，倒在阿伯纳西的怀里，周围到处都是哭泣的人们等等。那天晚上他回到雷（洛林）汽车旅馆，当时人们说他看起来得到了解放。他是那么欣喜若狂，像个大男孩一样，在发表完演讲后。他在汽车旅馆和他的工作人员共进晚餐。然后，这里是，这里是真正的人，对吧？有血有肉的人。他几乎可以肯定，那天晚上是和他的情妇乔治娅·戴维斯一起度过的，她是肯塔基州的州参议员，特意赶来和他过夜。她在他的圈子里是众所周知的。没有人对此感到惊讶。
They knew he was a man of flesh and blood. So he wakes up on Thursday, the 4th of April. It's the last day of his life. He meets immediately with his aides to discuss this legal business about the march. They're waiting for the Western District Court to pronounce. They're still confident the march will go ahead. He has lunch with Abernathy. His brother is there, AD, and they ring their mother in Atlanta
他们知道他是个有血有肉的男人。所以他在4月3日星期四醒来。这是他生命的最后一天。他立即与助手们会面，讨论关于游行的法律事务。他们在等待西区地方法院作出裁决。他们仍然相信游行会继续进行。他和阿伯纳西共进午餐。他的兄弟在场，AD，他们给亚特兰大的母亲打了电话
and they talk to her for an hour or so because his parents are still alive. Five o'clock, still no news. They meet the lawyers. He's still quite giddy. He and his aides have a pillow fight. I love that. Yeah. We should do more of that when we go on tour, Tom. We will. Over the rest of history. There's good news. The injunction seems to have been partially lifted. They will probably get their march in a few days time. So now we're at the end of the afternoon and he's getting ready for dinner. They're going to go to a local minister for Billy Carl's house. There's
和她聊了一个多小时，因为他的父母都还健在。五点钟，仍然没有消息。他们会见了律师。他仍然很高兴。他和他的助手们进行了一场枕头大战。我喜欢那个。是的。当我们去巡演时，我们应该多做点这个，汤姆。我们会做到的。在《历史其余部分》的旅程中。有好消息。禁令似乎已经被部分解除。他们大概几天后就能如愿进行游行了。所以现在已经是下午晚些时候了，他正在准备晚餐。他们要去当地一位牧师比利·卡尔的家。有
lots of banter about Billy Carl's wife and what a good cook she is. She's going to be cooking soul food, which is what King likes. Candied yams sounds terrible to me, as does pigs feet, neck bones and chitlins. What's corn pone? I don't know. I don't really know. It's one of those strange Southern things that I just try to pretend doesn't exist because it sounds so terrible.
很多关于比利·卡尔的妻子以及她有多会做饭的玩笑。她要做南方家常菜（soul food），那是金最喜欢的。蜜汁红薯听起来对我很糟糕，猪蹄、猪颈骨和炸猪皮也是。什么是玉米饼（corn pone）？我不知道。我真的不知道。那是那些奇怪的南方食物之一，我只是假装它不存在，因为它听起来太糟糕了。
Like turnip greens, which is also going to be having. I'm not a massive fan of this food. Our Southern listeners will be horrified by this. But King loves it. King loves it. He's delighted. He says, oh, it's going to be great. I can't wait. He goes to get. King loves it. He's delighted. He says, oh, it's going to be great.
就像芜菁甘蓝叶（turnip greens），他们也要吃这个。我不是这种食物的超级粉丝。我们的南方听众会被这个吓坏的。但金很喜欢。金很喜欢。他很高兴。他说，哦，这会很棒的。我等不及了。他去拿。金很喜欢。他很高兴。他说，哦，这会很棒的。
I can't wait. He goes to get into the bathroom to get ready for dinner. And usually he has to use a powder to shave rather than like cream and a razor. Why? Because he's got incredibly heavy stubble and only this sort of chemical that he puts on his face will get rid of it. It's called magic shaving powder, which is so American. Anyway, a doubtless lawsuit is brought against the manufacturers three years later. We'll get rid of it. It's called magic shaving powder, which says so American.
我等不及了。他走进浴室准备晚餐。通常他刮胡子得用粉末而不是剃须膏和剃刀。为什么？因为他的胡茬硬得难以置信，只有这种他抹在脸上的化学物质才能除掉它。它叫魔法剃须粉（magic shaving powder），太具有美国特色了。总之，毫无疑问，三年后针对制造商的诉讼被提起了。除掉它。它叫魔法剃须粉，太具有美国特色了。
Anyway, a doubtless, a lawsuit is brought against the manufacturers three years later. By the way, if you're from the magic shaving powder company, please sue Tom and not me. Yeah, I apologize for that. He, um, they're now running late and they have to go for dinner. He changes his shirt. He's put on weight. We said how unhealthy he was, you know, his lifestyle. So He's actually too fat for the first shirt that he puts on. He gets his tie.
总之，毫无疑问，三年后针对制造商的诉讼被提起了。顺便说一句，如果你来自魔法剃须粉公司，请起诉汤姆而不是我。是的，我为此道歉。他，嗯，他们现在快迟到了，不得不去吃晚饭。他换了衬衫。他体重增加。我们说过他有多不健康，你知道的，他的生活方式。所以他穿的第一件衬衫实际上太胖了，穿不下。他拿了他的领带。
He goes all this. He goes out on the balcony at 5.55. Ralph Abernathy is still getting ready. So this is the scene. This low slung motel just on the edge of downtown Memphis. He's standing there on the balcony for all to see in front of room 306. The motel, by the way, has been featured in local news reports about him being in Memphis.
他做完这一切。他在5点55分走到阳台上。拉尔夫·阿伯纳西还在准备。这就是当时的场景。这座低矮的汽车旅馆就坐落在孟菲斯市中心的边缘。他站在阳台上，让所有人都能看到，就在306房间前面。顺便说一句，这家汽车旅馆曾出现在当地关于他在孟菲斯的新闻报道中。
So everyone knows he's there. So everyone knows he's there. And the TV news pictures showed the room and the room number. So everybody knows he is there. There are police observers in a kind of firehouse on the other side of the street who have been watching him all this time. One of them says at this point there is Dr. King right there. I presume he's going to supper. He's there for a couple of minutes it's now 5.57 or so. He goes
所以每个人都知道他在那儿。所以每个人都知道他在那儿。电视新闻画面展示了房间和房间号。所以每个人都知道他在那儿。街对面消防局里的警察观察员一直在注视着他。其中一人在这个时候说，看，金博士就在那里。我想他是去吃晚饭的。他在那里待了几分钟，现在大约是5点57分。他走
inside to get his suit jacket. He puts it on. In the pockets there's a note that he's writing for a speech that he's going to give and the line that is written is, nothing is gained without sacrifice. He comes back out to the balcony, he's got his jacket on now. His driver is downstairs with his Cadillac and also downstairs are a group of other younger civil rights leaders, most notable of whom is Jesse Jackson, with whom Martin Luther King has had a slightly turbulent relationship. They've had a bit of a falling out. A very prominent political figure in the 80s, went he? Very prominent, exactly. The most prominent black leader in the 1980s and 1990s. And Jackson
进去拿他的西装外套。他穿上了它。口袋里有一张纸条，上面写着他准备发表的一演讲的草稿，写着的一行字是：不付出牺牲就什么也得不到。他重新走到阳台上，现在他穿上了夹克。他的司机和他的凯迪拉克在楼下，楼下还有一群其他较年轻的民权领袖，其中最著名的是杰西·杰克逊，马丁·路德·金与他的关系一直有些波折。他们曾有过一点争执。80年代非常著名的政治人物，对吧？非常显赫，没错。1980年代和1990年代最显赫的黑人领袖。而杰克逊
shouts out to him, our leader. And King says, ah, Jesse, I want you to come to dinner tonight. And this is a nice moment because it's a bit of reconciliation after the arguments they've had about civil rights strategy. It's now just gone past six o'clock. Jackson says, I've got this guy here who's a saxophonist. He's called Ben Branch. He's going to be doing a concert. He's going to be playing for the sanitation workers at the temple.
向他大喊，我们的领袖。金说，啊，杰西，我希望你今晚来吃晚饭。这是一个美好的时刻，在他们就民权策略发生争论之后，这是一个和解的时刻。现在刚过六点钟。杰克逊说，我这里有个人，是个萨克斯管手。他叫本·布兰奇。他要做一场音乐会。他要在圣殿为环卫工人演奏。
And King says, Ben, I want you to do this song, take my hand, precious Lord, sing it real pretty. And the guy says, I sure will doc. And then the driver gets out, Solomon Jones, he gets out of the car and he shouts up to King, he says, it's getting chilly. I think you're going to need a top coat. They're so solicitous about him. They're so protective of him.
金说，本，我希望你演奏这首歌，牵我手，亲爱的全能主（Take My Hand, Precious Lord），唱得动听一点。那个人说，我一定会的，博士。然后司机索洛蒙·琼斯下车了，他从车里出来，朝楼上的金大喊，他说，天变冷了。我想你需要一件大衣。他们对他是如此体贴。他们对他是如此保护。
You know, he means so much to these people. And King says the last words he ever says, okay, Jonesy, you really know how to take good care of me. And then he gets a menthol cigarette out of his pocket and he turns back from the railing to go back to his room to get this overcoat. And it's then that a single shot rings out deafening sound. Immediately everybody there knew that King had been shot. The parking lot is full of people screaming and shouting, get an ambulance, get an ambulance, oh my God, they've shot him, don't move him and
你知道的，他对这些人意义重大。金说了他生前说的最后一句话，好的，琼斯，你真知道怎么照顾好我。然后他从口袋里掏出一支薄荷烟，从栏杆旁转过身，准备回房间去拿这件大衣。就在这时，一声清脆的枪响划破空气，声音震耳欲聋。现场的每个人立刻都知道金被枪击了。停车场里挤满了尖叫和呐喊的人，叫救护车，叫救护车，天哪，他中枪了，别动他
all of this. The co-owner of the motel, who was a woman called Lurie Bailey, at this point had a stroke, fell into a coma and later died. Nobody talked about her, but she died at the same time. On the balcony they rush up. King is down. He has been hit on the right side of his jaw by a bullet, soft bullet that has expanded and has then ripped into his neck. There's massive
诸如此类。汽车旅馆的联合老板，一个名叫露里·贝利的女性，此时中风了，陷入昏迷并随后离世。没有人谈论过她，但她是在同一时间去世的。在阳台上，人们冲了上去。金倒下了。他的右下颌被一颗子弹击中，那是一颗软弹，击中后膨胀并撕裂了他的颈部。大量
bleeding. He's immediately in shock. His pulse is fading straight away. They rushed him to the nearest hospital, which was St. Joseph's hospital. He was at this point barely alive. He had effectively been killed almost instantly. I mean, very JFK, isn't it? The wound to the head, the absolutely fatal injury and people trying to resuscitate what can't be resuscitated. Exactly. 20 minutes after this moment, Jesse Jackson rings Coretta, his wife, in Atlanta. She's been out shopping with her daughter.
出血。他立刻陷入休克。他的脉搏瞬间微弱下去。他们把他紧急送往最近的医院，即圣约瑟夫医院。此时他已经生命垂危。实际上他几乎是瞬间遇害。我的意思是，这非常像肯尼迪遇刺，不是吗？头部中枪，绝对致命的伤势，人们试图对无法挽回的事情进行复苏。没错。在这个时刻过去20分钟后，杰西·杰克逊给他在亚特兰大的妻子科雷塔打了个电话。她当时正和女儿在外面购物。
At the same point, while Jackson's on the phone saying there's an accident, he's been hit on the shoulder so Jackson doesn't tell her the whole truth straight away, his boys who are watching TV see a newsflash about their father and they run into their mother to tell her. At this point, the surgeons are just about to get ready working on King. Right away, the chief neurosurgeon says to Ralph Abernathy, it will be a blessing if he dies, he has been so badly injured. He would have suffered a horrendous brain damage.
与此同时，当杰克逊在电话里说发生了一起事故，他的肩膀中弹了——所以杰克逊没有马上把全部真相告诉她——他的儿子们在看电视时看到了关于他们父亲的突发新闻，他们跑进屋里告诉母亲。此时，外科医生正准备对金进行手术。立刻，首席神经外科医生对拉尔夫·阿伯纳西说，如果他死了那将是一种解脱，他伤得太重了。他会遭受可怕的脑损伤。
Spine is cut and he has sustained awful brain damage. And actually the whole thing is done and dusted very quickly. Five minutes past seven, he is pronounced dead. His parents are listening in their local church in Atlanta, the Ebeneezer Baptist Church, King's Home Church. They're listening to the radio. It's a really, really sort of heart rending scene and they hear the news reports of their son has died. Now, what about the killer? Within moments, the police, who of course are there, right? They're spying on King. Yeah, they are on the scene. In the chaos in the car park of the
脊椎被切断，他遭受了可怕的脑损伤。实际上整个过程很快就结束了。七点零五分，他被宣布死亡。他的父母正在亚特兰大的当地教堂、埃比尼泽浸信会教堂（金的母会）里收听广播。这是一个非常、非常令人心碎的场景，他们听到了儿子去世的新闻报道。那么，凶手呢？转眼间，警察——当然他们就在现场，对吧？他们在监视金。是的，他们在现场。在
motel, they're like, where did the shot come from? All of King's friends point the same way to this particular kind of rundown looking brick house on South Main Street. So this was a boarding house run by a woman called Bessie Brewer. Americans would call it I think a rooming house or something like that. Hampton Sides wrote a brilliant book on the whole story about King's killer and the manhunt for him. And he says it was a haven for invalids, derelicts, transients, riverboat workers, and small-time crooks. The police basically pile into this house. And Dominic, can I just ask the police, is this the local police force or is this the FBI? It's the local police.
汽车旅馆停车场的混乱中，他们问，枪声是从哪里来的？金的所有朋友都指向同一个方向，指向南大街上一栋看起来破旧的砖房。这是一栋由一位名叫贝西·布鲁尔的女性经营的寄宿公寓。美国人我想会称之为分租房（rooming house）或类似的名字。汉普顿·赛兹写了一本关于金的凶手和对他的搜捕行动的精彩书籍。他说那是残疾人、流浪汉、瞬息过客、内河船员和小偷小摸者的避难所。警察基本上蜂拥闯入这所房子。多米尼克，请问警察，这是当地警察局还是联邦调查局？是当地警察。
It's the local police because it's the local police who are on the scene. But the FBI get involved almost immediately. And how does Hoover feel about that? Really interesting this. So Hoover obviously despises King, but the interesting thing, Sir Hampton Sides in his book talks about this. It's the biggest manhunt in FBI history. Hoover had working on it 3,500 agents and they spent $200 million to track down King's
是当地警察，因为在现场的是当地警察。但联邦调查局几乎立刻就介入了。胡佛对此有何感想？这非常有趣。所以胡佛显然鄙视金，但有趣的是，汉普顿·赛兹在他的书中谈到了这一点。这是联邦调查局历史上最大规模的搜捕行动。胡佛派出了3500名特工参与其中，他们花费了2亿美元来追捕金的
killer. And the interesting thing is the one thing Hoover cared about most of all, apart from a lot of very insolubrious things was the reputation of the Bureau. That meant more to him than anything. To capture King's assassin would be good for the FBI. He will not be accused. He does not want to be accused of having gone soft on this because of racism. He wants to show the world that the FBI will crack this case, we are the best in the world
凶手。有趣的是，胡佛最关心的唯一一件事，除了许多非常见不得光的事情之外，就是局里的声誉。这对他来说比什么都重要。抓获金的刺客对联邦调查局是有利的。他不会被指控。他不希望被指控因为种族主义而对此手软。他想向世界证明，联邦调查局会破获这起案件，我们是世界上最擅长做这件事的，无论受害者是谁。
at doing this, no matter who the victim is. So is Hoover's contempt for Martin Luther King, is that racist or political? Oh, I think both. I think probably both. I think a bit of both actually. I think the two are fused in Hoover's mind. He regards the civil rights movement as a subversive communist, all of this kind of stuff.
所以胡佛对马丁·路德·金的蔑视，是出于种族主义还是政治原因？哦，我想两者皆有。我想可能两者皆有。实际上我觉得两者兼而有之。我认为这两者在胡佛的脑海中是融合在一起的。他视民权运动为颠覆性的共产主义，所有这些东西。
And undoubtedly there's a racial dimension to that, but there's a kind of political ideological one as well, I would say. So I don't want to sound like a stuck record on these American assassinations, but as for the Kennedy assassination, you could say the law enforcement authorities are actually really good because within an hour they know, or they're pretty sure the shot has come from room 5B which was being occupied by a man called John Willard. They've also found the weapon which was left near the scene. It's a Remington Game Master rifle but Willard himself has completely vanished. He's nowhere to be seen.
毫无疑问，其中有种族维度，但我会说，也有政治意识形态层面的因素。所以我不希望在这些美国刺杀事件上听起来像个复读机，但就像肯尼迪遇刺案一样，你可以说执法当局其实非常出色，因为在一小时内他们就知道，或者相当确信枪声来自5B房间，该房间当时被一个名叫约翰·威拉德（John Willard）的男子占用。他们还在现场附近找到了遗留的武器。那是一支雷明顿猎鹿大师步枪（Remington Game Master rifle），但威拉德本人已经彻底消失了。他无影无踪。
So this manhunt begins. They eventually work out that Willard is probably a man who's going by a series of other aliases. The one he uses most is Eric Stavro Gault. I've never heard of a more obvious eudonym. Yeah. Especially because this is clearly based on Stavro Blofeldt. Yeah.
于是这场搜捕开始了。他们最终查明，威拉德很可能是使用了一系列其他化名的人。他用得最多的一个是埃里克·斯塔夫罗·加尔特（Eric Stavro Gault）。我从来没听过这么明显的假名。是的。尤其是因为这显然是基于斯塔夫罗·布洛菲尔德（Stavro Blofeldt）。
So they work out that this guy Gault has fled Memphis in a Ford Mustang. He drove to Atlanta and then he got a series of buses and he's ended up in Toronto, in Toronto, he hung around there for a considerable time. He stole the identity of a policeman called Ramon George Snade. I mean, that was actually really his name. It wasn't it. policeman called Ramon George Snaid. I mean, that was actually really his name. It wasn't.
所以他们查明，这个叫加尔特的家伙开着一辆福特野马逃离了孟菲斯。他开车去了亚特兰大，然后换乘了一系列长途汽车，最后来到了多伦多。在多伦多，他在那里流连了相当长的一段时间。他偷了一个名叫拉蒙·乔治·斯内德（Ramon George Snade）的警察的身份。我的意思是，那其实真的是他的名字。不是吗？一个名叫拉蒙·乔治·斯内德的警察。我的意思是，那其实真的是他的名字。不是。
And he flew to London and his dream was to go to Rhodesia to the white supremacist colony that had broken away from Britain, declared independence unilaterally. Ian Smith and all that. Ian Smith. He wants to become a mercenary fighting for the Rhoditians. This guy, Eric Stavro Gault. He hung around in Earl's Court to try to make contact. So unexpected, so unexpected that this story, which is so American ends up in Earl's Court, which is the first place that we stayed when we moved to London.
他飞往伦敦，他的梦想是去罗得西亚，那个脱离英国、单方面宣布独立的白人至上主义殖民地。伊恩·史密斯和那些人。伊恩·史密斯。他想成为一名为罗得西亚人作战的雇佣兵。这个叫埃里克·斯塔夫罗·加尔特的家伙。他在伯爵宫（Earl's Court）闲逛，试图建立联系。如此出人意料，这个如此具有美国特色的故事竟然以伯爵宫告终，那也是我们搬到伦敦时住的第一个地方。
Oh, so he tried to make contact with radiation mercenaries. He did the obvious thing, which is he got in touch with the Daily Telegraph. Right, right. Not the Guardian. No, and said, you seem like sound fellows. Would you be able to put me in touch with these incredibly racist mercenaries? While they're trying to do that, and that doesn't really work out, he tried and failed to burglar a jeweler's shop in Paddington, but he did succeed in robbing a branch of the TSB bank in Fulham. I mean, just an incredible... To us, you're British.
哦，所以他试图与罗得西亚雇佣兵建立联系。他做了最显而易见的事，那就是他联系了《每日电讯报》。对，对。而不是《卫报》。不，并说，你们看起来像是靠谱的人。你们能帮我联系到这些极其种族主义的雇佣兵吗？正当他们试图这样做——而这并没有真正成功时，他尝试并失败地盗窃了帕丁顿的一家珠宝店，但他成功抢劫了富勒姆（Fulham）的一家TSB银行分行。我的意思是，简直不可思议……对我们来说，你是英国人。
All this stuff about grits and weird Southern food and suddenly the TSB in Fulham. Exactly. The FBI by this point had worked out what was going on. This guy, Snade, is Gault, is Willard, and is clearly going to be somebody else. They sent instructions to London and eventually he was stopped at Heathrow Airport by Scotland Yard trying to fly to Brussels to join up with African mercenaries there. Under interrogation it turns out that he is actually a man called James Earl Ray, who is from, I mean, he is classic kind of semi-criminal underclass.
所有这些关于玉米粗粉（grits）和奇怪的南方食物的东西，突然间就到了富勒姆的TSB。没错。联邦调查局此时已经弄清了是怎么回事。这个叫斯内德的家伙，就是加尔特，就是威拉德，显然还会是别人。他们向伦敦发出了指令，最终他在希思罗机场被苏格兰场拦下，当时他正试图飞往那里的非洲雇佣兵会合。在审讯中，证明他实际上是一个名叫詹姆斯·厄尔·雷（James Earl Ray）的人，来自——我的意思是，他是典型的半犯罪底层阶级。
He is a high school dropout from a violent, rural, poor background. He is virulently racist. He's been in and out of prison. He had escaped in 1967 from the Missouri State Penitentiary, hidden in a, he'd been hiding in a load of bread, in a crate full of bread. Did he have a ball on a chain that he carried as he hid in the crate? Yeah, from one of those stripy uniforms.
他是从一个暴力、农村、贫困背景中辍学的高中生。他是个狂热的种族主义者。他屡次进出监狱。他在1967年从密苏里州立监狱越狱，藏在一车面包里，在一板条箱满满的面包里。他藏在板条箱里时还带着拴在链子上的铁球吗？是的，穿着那种条纹制服。
Stripy uniforms with a cap. He used to work in the prison bakery and this is how he'd managed to escape in this sort of bread van. Then he'd ended up in Los Angeles calling himself Gault. He'd been a loner. He had been involved in Los Angeles with the campaign of a man we'll be talking about later in this series, George Wallace, independent candidate, governor of Alabama, running for president and he'd been part of the effort to get Wallace onto the California ballot.
穿着带帽子的条纹制服。他过去曾在监狱的烘焙坊工作，这就是他设法在这种面包车里成功越狱的方式。然后他流落到洛杉矶，自称加尔特。他一直是个独行侠。他在洛杉矶参与了一个人的竞选活动，我们将在本系列的后面谈到他——乔治·华莱士（George Wallace），独立候选人，阿拉巴马州州长，竞选总统，他曾是让华莱士名字出现在加利福尼亚州选票上的努力的一部分。
He also seems to have been stalking Martin Luther King for months. Police found in his apartment in Los Angeles, they found a map of Atlanta with King's house and his church circled. At first, James Earl Ray confessed and he pleaded guilty. And by doing that, he avoided the electric chair to which he would have been sent if he had tried to contest the charge. But as soon as he's been sentenced, which is to 99 years in prison, he then immediately recants and says, I didn't do it at all. Which of course has given rise to conspiracy theories ever since, even though of all the assassinations,
他似乎也已经追踪马丁·路德·金好几个月了。警察在他在洛杉矶的公寓里发现了一张亚特兰大的地图，上面圈出了金的房子和他的教堂。起初，詹姆斯·厄尔·雷招供了，并且他认罪了。通过这样做，他避免了电椅死刑，如果他试图对指控进行抗辩的话，他本会被送上电椅。但就在他被判处99年监禁后，他立即翻供，并说，我根本没做过。当然，这自此引发了各种阴谋论，尽管在所有的暗杀事件中
I think this is probably, well, it is probably one of the most clear cuts. He briefly escaped. I didn't know this until I read up on this in 1977. Again, not bread based, I think this time, but was recaptured after three days and he died in 1998, aged 70, still protesting his innocence and saying that he had been framed rather like Lee of Oswald I suppose. But back to Martin Luther King just to tie up that story his funeral is in Atlanta on the 9th of April a hundred and fifty thousand people came LBJ did not go. But he had announced the day of mourning hadn't he?
我想这可能是，嗯，这绝对是最明确的案件之一。他曾短暂越狱。我直到1977年读到相关资料时才知道这一点。这一次又不是靠面包越狱了，我想，但在三天后被重新抓获，他于1998年去世，享年70岁，至死都在坚称自己是清白的，并说他是被人诬陷的，就像李·Harvey·奥斯瓦尔德一样，我想。但言归正传，为了给马丁·路德·金的故事做一个结尾，他的葬礼于4月9日在亚特兰大举行，十五万人参加了，林登·约翰逊（LBJ）没有去。但他不是宣布过哀悼日吗？
He had done, he had done. Yes he had. First ever in American history for a private citizen. But Nixon goes. Nixon went and Nixon also visited King's widow privately. Reagan didn't go. And I have to say Reagan rather let himself down with his reaction to Martin Luther King's death. He said, it's the end of a great tragedy that began when we began compromising with law and order and people started choosing which laws they would like to break, which basically was Reagan's way of hinting that he didn't approve of the civil rights movement, which I don't think personally, I don't think reflects terribly well on Reagan. The Memphis strike was settled a week later under pressure from the White House.
他确实宣布过，确实如此。是的，他宣布了。这在美利坚历史上尚属首次，是针对一位普通公民的。但尼克松去了。尼克松去了，尼克松还私下拜访了金的遗孀。里根没有去。而且我必须说，里根对马丁·路德·金之死的反应实在是太让人失望了。他说，这是一场伟大悲剧的结束，这场悲剧始于我们开始对法律和秩序妥协，人们开始选择自己想要触犯的法律，这基本上是里根在暗示他并不赞同民权运动，个人认为，这在很大程度上反映出里根并不怎么光彩。孟菲斯罢工在白宫的压力下一周后得到了解决。
The Johnson White House said, you know, you got to tie this thing up. So the strikers basically got everything they wanted. Their campaign had worked. But just as King's Aids had predicted the poor people's campaign, this kind of biblically inspired campaign that was his last great effort was a complete and utter disaster. This resurrection city, the shanty town was a complete nightmare. The rain poured down.
约翰逊的白宫表示，你知道，你得把这件事了结。所以罢工者基本上得到了他们想要的一切。他们的运动成功了。但正如金的助手们所预测的那样，穷人运动——这场具有圣经启示意义、也是他最后一次伟大努力的运动——却是一场彻头彻尾的巨大灾难。这个“复兴城”，也就是那个贫民窟，简直是一场噩梦。大雨倾盆。
It was incredibly badly organized. There was a lot of violence. It was a very depressing monument to King's career. But actually all of that is eclipsed by what happens in the days immediately after King's death. So LBJ, as you said, Tom, he went on television straight away and he said, we'll have a day of mourning. Please, will nobody react to this with violence? But actually violence had already begun even as he was speaking. The Black Power architect Stokely Carmichael said, when white America killed Dr. King she declared war on us. The rebellions that have been occurring around this country are just light stuff compared with what's about to happen. And he was right. San Washington DC
组织工作简直糟透了。发生了大量的暴力事件。这是对金的职业生涯的一个非常令人沮丧的纪念碑。但事实上，这一切都被金死后几天内发生的事情给掩盖了。所以正如你所说，汤姆，LBJ马上上了电视，他说，我们将举行哀悼日。拜托，请任何人不要用暴力来回应此事！但事实上，就在他讲话的时候，暴力已经开始了。黑人权力运动的建筑师斯托克利·卡迈尔说：“当白人美利坚杀死金博士时，她向我们宣战了。与即将发生的事情相比，这个国家各地一直在发生的叛乱只是小菜一碟。”他是对的。华盛顿特区
alone. By that evening, large parts of the city are on fire. Hundreds of stores have been looted. There is kind of fighting in the streets. This continues the following day. So by the 5th of April, around about lunchtime, the center of the city is kind of deserted because people have effectively fled the downtown area. There's huge fires. There is smoke, so much smoke that it gets into the White House. By nightfall, the whole of the city is covered with this pool of black smoke. LBJ has called for troops to enter the Capitol. So troops have occupied most of the central area. They're ringing the White House and the Capitol, the Congress.
仅华盛顿特区。到那天傍晚，城市的很大一部分都在燃烧。数以百计的商店被洗劫一空。街头发生了某种战斗。这种情况第二天仍在继续。因此，到了4月5日左右的午餐时间，市中心几乎空无一人，因为人们实际上已经逃离了市中心区域。到处都是大火。有烟雾，浓烟滚滚，甚至飘进了白宫。夜幕降临，整座城市都被这团黑烟笼罩。LBJ已下令军队进入首都。因此，军队占领了大部分中心区域。他们包围了白宫、国会山和国会。
There are kind of sandbags everywhere. There are floodlights burning to illuminate the White House. There are machine gun nests that have been set up. And you say that these soldiers have come from Vietnam. I mean, what a grim irony. Exactly. What an unbelievable irony. I mean, as people said at the time, to use the phrase that was so common in the
到处都是沙袋。强光灯通明，照亮了白宫。架设了机枪阵地。你说这些士兵是从越南来的。我的天，这是多么残酷的讽刺啊。确实。多么令人难以置信的讽刺啊。正如当时人们所说的那样，用那个在
late sixties, the war has come home. Blowback. Yeah. To the heart of America's cities. LBJ who is in there in the White Houses, the war has come home, blow back. Yeah. To the heart of America's cities. LBJ who is in there in the white house, you know, the smoke outside surrounded by soldiers, this apocalyptic atmosphere. Some of his aides say to him, God, this is terrible. And he says to them, you know, what did you expect?
六年代末非常流行的词来说，战争回到了本土。自食其果。是的。来到了美国城市的中心。身处白宫之中的LBJ，战争回到了本土，自食其果。是的。来到了美国城市的中心。身处白宫之中的LBJ，你知道，外面浓烟滚滚，四周都是士兵，这种末日般的氛围。他的一些助手对他说，天哪，这太可怕了。他对他们说，你知道，你期待什么呢？
Why are we surprised? And I quote, when you put your foot on a man's neck and hold him down for 300 years, and then you let him up, what's he going to do? He's going to do? He's going to knock your block off. And what happened in Washington is mirrored all across the country, in Chicago and Pittsburgh, in Kansas City, a hundred cities burn. There are dozens of people are shot dead by the police or by the National Guard.
我们为什么还要大惊小怪呢？我引述他的话：“当你把脚踩在一个人的脖子上，把他按倒在地300年，然后你让他起来，他会怎么做？他会怎么做？他会把你打得满地找牙。”华盛顿发生的事情在全国各地都在重演，在芝加哥、匹兹堡、堪萨斯城，上百座城市在燃烧。有几十人被警察或国民警卫队开枪打死。
Thousands of people are injured. Tens of thousands of people arrested. I mean, it is an unbelievably apocalyptic scene, but there is one exception. There is one city where you would expect trouble and there is numb. And that's the city we began with Indianapolis. Cause that's where Robert Kennedy, who is on his campaign, stands up and he gives yet another incredibly resonant, powerful, emotional piece of oratory. That's what we began with and extemporized.
成千上万的人受伤。数以万计的人被捕。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的末日般的场景，但有一个例外。有一个城市，你本以为会出乱子，结果却一片平静。那就是我们开始时提到的城市——印第安纳波利斯。因为罗伯特·肯尼迪正是在那里参加他的竞选活动，他站出来发表了又一篇极具共鸣、充满力量、感人至深的演讲。这就是我们开场时提到的、即兴发表的演讲。
And we will return to that speech and to Robert Kennedy and to his campaign and his own tragic fate in the next episode of this series. That's a huge thrill for all fans of my impression of Robert Kennedy, because it will be featuring again in our next episode. And if you want to hear that and Dominic's account of Kennedy's campaign and of course his assassination, then that will be the next episode that we do. And if you want to hear it immediately and the rest of the series as well, then you can go right now to therestishhistory.com and join the club.
我们将在本系列的下一集中重新回到那场演讲、罗伯特·肯尼迪以及他的竞选活动和他自己的悲惨命运。这对于所有喜欢我模仿罗伯特·肯尼迪的粉丝来说是一个巨大的惊喜，因为这个环节将在我们的下一集中再次出现。如果你想听这一集，以及多米尼克对肯尼迪竞选活动以及当然还有他的暗杀事件的叙述，那么这将是我们制作的下一集。如果你想立刻收听以及本系列的其余部分，那么你可以立即访问therestishhistory.com加入俱乐部。
But either way, we will be back with you very soon. Bye bye. Bye. Hello everybody, Dominic here. Now I have some very good news for you because if you've been enjoying the series that we're doing on America in 1968 and my tangled relationship with Eugene McCarthy, the news couldn't be better actually because on Tuesday the 5th of November, thrilling news for people who like American politics, I will be covering the American presidential election through
但无论如何，我们很快就会回到你们身边。再见。再见。大家好，我是多米尼克。现在我有一个非常好的消息要告诉大家，因为如果你一直喜欢我们制作的关于1968年美国的系列节目，以及我和尤金·麦卡锡之间纠葛的关系，那消息真的不能再好了，因为在11月5日星期二，对于喜欢美国政治的人来说是个振奋人心的消息，我将通宵报道美国总统大选，
the night, live from New York City. Now, the downside of this for people who enjoy very poor American accents and stories about the Punic Wars, the Bannies, if you're one of that sort of embattled minority, Tom Holland will not be joining us. He's not allowed to come. I will be joined by, unbelievably, Rory Stewart and Alistair Campbell from The Rest Is Politics, Anthony Scaramucci from The Rest Is Politics US and Marina Hyde from The Rest Is Entertainment. Alan Shearer from The Rest Is Football was invited, but he didn't want to come.
从纽约市现场直播。现在，对于那些喜欢糟糕的美国口音和布匿战争故事的人来说，这算是一个缺点，也就是巴尼迷们，如果你是那种处于劣势的少数群体之一，汤姆·霍兰将不会加入我们。他不被允许来。与我一同出席的将有，难以置信的是，来自《剩余历史》的罗里·斯图尔特和阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔，来自《剩余历史：美国》的安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，以及来自《剩余娱乐》的玛丽娜·海德。来自《剩余足球》的阿兰·希勒也被邀请了，但他不想来。
We will be live on YouTube from 3pm Eastern time on Tuesday afternoon and we'll be back again dementedly at midnight terrifying prospect to take you through the early hours of Wednesday morning we will be analyzing all the events as they unfold I read we will be comparing 2024 to elections past in American history and we'll be reacting to the unveiling of the next president of the United States. Now I know that Rest is History listeners are not necessarily the same persuasion as those of our sister podcasts.
我们将于周二下午美国东部时间下午3点开始在YouTube上进行直播，并将在午夜再次疯狂回归，这是一个令人毛骨悚然的前景，将带领大家度过周三清晨的时光，我们将分析所有展开的事件，我读到我们将把2024年与美国历史上的历届大选进行比较，我们将对美国下一任总统的揭晓做出反应。我知道《剩余历史》的听众不一定和我们姊妹播客的听众持有相同的政治倾向。
So to allay your fears for every mention of Donald Trump or Boris Johnson that Alistair Campbell makes, I will ensure that viewers get at least six anecdotes about Hubert Humphrey or George Wallace. For more information, why wouldn't you want more information on such a galaxy of stars? Just search for The Rest Is Politics America Decides on YouTube. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，为了消除你们的担忧，阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔每提到一次唐纳德·特朗普或鲍里斯·约翰逊，我都会确保观众至少听到六个关于休伯特·汉弗莱或乔治·华莱士的轶事。想要了解更多信息，为什么你不想在这样一群群星璀璨的嘉宾身上了解更多信息呢？只需在YouTube上搜索“The Rest Is Politics America Decides”。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。